bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur Public
Sénat par 189 voix contre 134 le Sénat a
adopté hier soir une proposition de loi
socialiste sur le déblocage exceptionnel
de la participation salariale et de
l'investissement un texte pourtant
rejeté il y a quelques jours en
commission un texte qui reprend un
engagement de François Hollande en mars
dernier le chef de l'État avait annoncé
que ces fonds normalement indisponibles
pendant 5 ans pourrai être débloqué
pendant 6 mois sans pénalité fiscale
avec toutefois une limite fixée à 20000
€ objectif de cette mesure relancer la
consommation je vous propose donc tout
de suite de revivre cette séance qui
avait lieu hier soir mes chers collègues
l'ordre du jour appelle maintenant la
discussion de la proposition de loi de
adopté par l'Assemblée nationale après
engagement de la procédure accélérée
portant dé blocagees exceptionnel de la
participation et de l'intéressement dans
la discussion générale la parole est au
ministre à Monsieur Benoît amont
ministre chargé de l'économie sociale et
solidaire et de la
consommation monsieur le président
monsieur le
Président Madame la rapporteur mesdames
et Messieurs les les
sénateurs je viens donc évoquer la
proposition de loi à l'initiative de de
du groupe socialiste à l'Assemblée
nationale sur euh le déblocage de
l'épargne salariale et la possibilité
donc pour les salariés de débloquer de
manière exceptionnelle euh euh une
partie de leur éparre salarial pendant
une période d'une durée de de 6 mois je
veux dire que cette mesure est une
mesure prise en cohérence avec d'autres
orientations du gouvernement en matière
de soutien à l'activité économique et à
la croissance la première concerne
évidemment la création d'un
environnement européen plus favorable à
la croissance et qui tienneent compte de
rythme de consolidation budgétaire qui
n'altère pas les possibilités de reprise
dans l'Union européenne travail qui a
trouvé une première traduction dans la
réorientation de la politique européenne
et le changement de doctrine de la
Commission européenne sur les rythmes de
consolidation budgétaire la deuxème
priorité c'est la restauration de la
compétitivité de nos entreprises la
restauration de leur marge pour qu'elle
crée à nouveau de l'emploi c'est le sens
de la mesure de crédit d'impôt euh
compétitivité emploi une mesure qui est
d'ors et déjà préfinancée et qui devrait
permettre aux entreprises de de
restaurer leur Marg donc leur
compétitivité leur capacité exportatrice
et leur capacité donc à créer de
l'emploi enfin le soutien à la
consommation et le dernier pilier de
cette stratégie de croissance soutien à
la consommation altéré les ces dernières
années puisque pour la première fois le
pouvoir d'achat des Français a reculé il
a reculé de manière
suffisamment significative pour qu'il
affecte la cons tion c'est là un pilier
pourtant fondamental de de de l'activité
en France qu'il est nécessaire
évidemment de restaurer et c'est le sens
de la proposition qui a faite le
président de la République le 28 mars
qui a annoncé sa volonté d'ouvrir la
possibilité donc d'un déblocage
exceptionnel de la participation de
l'intéressement de l'épargne salariale
pendant une période de 6 mois nous avons
voulu que cette mesure soit la plus
simple et la plus lisible qui soit de
façon à ce qu'elle ne porte pas atteinte
ni à l'épargne longue ni à l'épargne
solidaire mais qu'elle encourage
concrètement la consommation l'épargne
salarial venit pas sans le savoir ce
sont à peu près 90 milliards aujourd'hui
d'encours et la part des sommes bloquées
au sein de cet encours global concerne
environ 4 millions de salariés français
4 millions de salariés français qui
pourraient faire usage selon leur besoin
d'une partie de cette épargne salariale
pour consommer nous avons voulu donc euh
euh flécher l'utilisation de cette
épargne salariale vers la consommation
et je me réjouis que l'Assemblée
nationale nous ait aidé à cibler
l'utilisation qui sera faite de cette
épaggne salariale pour éviter que le
déblocage de cette de ces sommes
ailleent abond d'autres produits
financiers dont certains Français
pourraient attendre une meilleure un
meilleur rendement une meilleure
rémunération nous avons souhaiter au
diapason de l'Assemblée nationale que
l'on puisse cibler l'utilisation qui
sera FA en fait de ces 20000 € maximum
puisque c'est jusqu'à 20000 € que les
Français pourront débloquer et je veux
commencer en évoquant tout de suite en
entrant dans le débat parce que je sais
que plusieurs parlementaires sénateurs
notamment issu de l'UDI ont souhaitait
renforcer encore ce ciblage au travers
d'un d'un amendement amendement qui
préconise que les sommes débloqué par
les Français soit uniquement utilisé à
l'achat de service et pas à l'achat de
bien d'équipement au motif et et
l'argument et la philosophie est louable
que les emplois en matière de service
sont des emplois localisés en France et
non pas des emplois localisés à
l'extérieur ce qui peut-être le cas
effectivement quand il s'agit de
fourniture de bien d'équipement et on
pense à un téléviseur notamment parfois
une automobile même si évidemment on
fabrique aussi et heureusement des
automobiles en France et je voudrais
dire tout de suite que nous ne
souhaitons pas en tout cas le
gouvernement ne souhaite pas que l'on
limite de trop la portée d'une telle
mesure pourquoi parce que dans la
réalité aujourd'hui si on devait
réfléchir à ne limiter qu'aux achats de
service une mesure de déblocage de
l'épargne salariale je prends l'exemple
d'une personne qui voudrait acheter une
cuisine et donc s'équipé d'une cuisine
peu importe chez qui mol balpa hgena peu
importe la réalité c'est que dans une
cuisine vous avez un service la pose
mais vous avez aussi des biens les
meubles vous avez des biens la
cuisinière un réfrigérateur et que vous
achetez et un bien et un service et le
fait de limiter donc le déblocage de
l'épargne salariale uniquement au
service risquerait de freiner les choix
la volonté parfois même le besoin d'un
certain nombre de salariés et bien
d'équiper leur maison d'une veréranda
d'équiper leur maison d'une cuisine et
c'est là un premier argument je
comprends la volonté de soutenir le
secteur du du bâtiment mais je ne crois
pas qu'en empêchant les salariés
français de s'acheter des biens
d'équipement on renforce pour autant les
achats de services dans le domaine du du
bâtiment je crains même que l'on
restregne cela je veux dire cela et et
je même si je comprends parfaitement la
logique qui est celle des sénateurs et
et l'intention je crois il partage la
philosophie générale de ce texte mais je
voudrais rajouter un autre argument
parce que je crois que c'est un des
points de débat les les plus importants
que nous avons aujourd'hui quand on
achète des services effectivement on
achète des emplois localisés mais quand
on achète des bi on nachète pas que des
biens fabriqués en Corée ou au Japon
quand on achète une automobile c'est
aussi des automobiles heureusement pour
une bonne partie d'entre ell peu par
fabriqué par Peugeot et par Renault
fabriqué ici or le déblocage de
l'épargne salariale nous permettra de
déstocker un bon nombre de véhicules
aujourd'hui qui sont conservés par les
concessionnaires mais de surcrois même
quand on achète un bien importé combien
sont-ils ces emplois liés au servicees
clientèle de ce som de grandes marques
qui commercialis de l'électroménager et
qui sont localisés ici combien sont-ils
ces emplois de la grande distribution
qui sont euh créés ici parce que l'on
achète des produits peu importe qu'ils
soient fabriqués ici ou ailleurs et je
veux dire donc le fait de soutenir la
consommation des ménages et la
consommation de bien d'équipement
soutient aussi l'emploi en France et si
je peux me permettre une réflexion
supplémentaire comme ministre en charge
de l'économie sociale et solidaire il se
développe une vertu aujourd'hui dans euh
le secteur de l'électroménager notamment
ou des biens d'équipement c'est qu'à
côté de la commercialisation de ces
biens se développe une fili de la
réparation avec des emplois localisés
ici et ces emplois sont soutenus par
l'achat de ces biens donc je considère
aujourd'hui que nous avons là un
ensemble d'arguments qui devrait
justifier qu'on en reste à la rédaction
du du texte tel qu'il est c'est-à-dire
un texte qui ne limite pas les achats à
l'achat de service mais soit bien à
l'achat de biens et de service voilà ce
je voulais donner ces ces arguments à ce
stade la lisibilité de ce texte est
aussi de de de fixer une période une
période de 6 mois qui commencera donc au
1er juillet jusqu'au 31 décembre mais
nous avons voulu poser un certain nombre
de gardesfous les deux
gardesfous essentiels sont d'abord que
notre choix s'est porté sur un
dispositif qui préserve l'épargne placé
en vue de la retraite dans les percos
pour éviter que cet investissement qui
consiste à préparer le futur ne soit pas
sacrifié à un besoin immédiat de
consommation donc nous nous nousous nous
consolidons les perc mais mais nous
préserverons aussi les les fonds
solidaires alors pourquoi ce statut
particulier pour les fonds solidaires
parce que les besoins des entreprise de
l'économie sociale et solidaire en
raison de leur modèle capitalistique
sont différents des besoins des
entreprises dites de l'économie
classique elles ont un fonctionnement
beaucoup plus tempérant beaucoup plus
patient qui suppose de disposer de de
l'accès à des financements pérennes dont
les fonds solidaires d'où la nécessité
de les préserver de ce dispositif qui
qui qui en tout cas de de les mettre à
l'écart de ce dispositif de déblocage
exceptionnel de l'intéressement de la
participation qui plus généralement ne
remet pas en cause ce que nous
considérons être un outil fondamental
d'association des salariés à la
performance de l'entreprise mais en
rappelant aussi que la participation
l'intéressement l'épargne salariale ce
ne sont pas des outils de rémunération
des travails ce sont des outils de
partage des profits d'intéressement à la
performance qui n'est pas exactement
la même philosophie et que ce modèle
original qui est celui de la France
justifie d'être consolidé pourquoi parce
qu'il est de surcroit un objet de
dialogue social qui fonctionne plutôt
bien la réforme
donc que nous vous proposons en tout cas
cette mesure
exceptionnelle anticipe ou en tout cas
ne préjuge pas plutôt de ce qui sera la
réforme plus globale de l'épargne
salariale avec l'installation du copias
pardon pour ceux qui ne connaîtrait pas
le le copiesas conseil d'orientation de
la participation l'intéressement de
l'épargne salariale et de l'actionnariat
salarié un conseil qui devra préparer
une réforme plus globale pour répondre à
à trois objectifs et et je conclurai si
vous voulez bien pour ne pas être trop
long par cela le premier c'est d'élargir
le bénéfice de de l'épargne salariale il
y a aujourd'hui 8,8 millions de salariés
qui bénéficient d'au moins un de ces
dispositifs euh en en réalité 8,8
millions de salariés tout cela cache des
inégalités qui sont des inégalités
extrêmement fortes puisque moins d'un
salarié sur 5 des entreprises de moins
de 50 salariés a accès à un de ces
dispositifs et que quand on regarde les
grandes entreprises près de 2 ti3 des
salariés des grandes entreprises ont
accès à tous ces dispositifs qui
s'agisse d'un dispositif d'intéressement
de participation un plan d'épargne
entreprise ou un PERCO on voit bien
qu'il y a là des inégalités qu'il faut
faut pouvoir lever et notre volonté est
que la réforme globale de l'épargne
salariale bâtie en lien avec les
partenaires sociaux élargissent le
bénéfice de ces dispositifs sans pour
autant bouleverser l'équilibre qui doit
demeurer entre la rémunération du
travail par les salaires et les outils
de de participation à nos yeux la
participation ne doit pas être un
substitut ou un palliatif au salaire je
vous rappelle par ailleurs qu'elle ne
bénéficie pas du même régime de
contribution sociale et le salaire est
un instrument aujourd'hui
essentiel de financement de la sécurité
sociale et c'est pour ça que en
soutenant l'élargissement de la
participation et l'épargne salariale
nous ne voulons pas remettre en cause le
principe une politique qui doit pour
rémunérer les salarier reposer d'abord
sur le salaire deuxème enjeu la
simplification faut-il rappeler qu'il y
a eu 10 lois depuis 2001 un empilement
considérable de règles nouvelles qui
amène à ce que le dispositif est de plus
en plus complexe fait d'ailleurs l'objet
presque d'un raffinement extrême et il
s'agit pour nous de le
simplifier pour répondre à des questions
assez simples quel est le bon niveau
d'association aujourd'hui des salariés
au profit qui soient adaptés à
l'entreprise et quels sont les critères
de performance pour faire de ces outils
des levier au service de la productivité
de la compétitivité des entreprises nous
devons répondre à ces questions avec les
partenaires sociaux dernier enjeu de ce
que doit être une réforme plus globale
de l'épargne salariale c'est le fait que
ces 90 milliards en cours aillent au
financement de l'investissement
productif il est frappant de constater
qu'il y a des liquidités abondante dans
l'économie européenne mais qu'une grande
partie de ces liquidités vont à des
investissements refuges et pas à des
investissements productif c'est ce qu'on
appelle les fameuses trappes à liquidité
nous avons donc un enjeu tout à fait
fondamental à faire en sorte que cette
épargne salariale aille financer de
l'investissement productif et je me
réjouis du fait que les partenaires
sociaux et saluer le le montant
aujourd'hui des encours de l'encours des
fonds socialement responsable 10
milliards d'euros c'est la preuve que on
est capable à partir de cette épargne
d'en faire une source pérenne robuste
participative tempérante de financement
des entreprises ce qui est notre
objectif une mesure de consommation de
soutien à l'activité je vous le dis je
je pense que toute mesure qui tend à
restreindre le
champ de
d'application d'une telle disposition
est une mesure dont on anticipe qu'elle
n'aura pas d'effet sur l'économie et
l'enjeu il est là oui ou non
voulons-nous que cette mesure ait un
impact non seulement sur le pouvoir
d'achat mais sur la consommation donc
sur la croissance et l'emploi toute
disposition qui restreint est une
disposition qui vise à pour des intérêts
qui ne sont pas forcément ni celui du
consommateur ni celui de l'emploi à
faire de cette mesure une mesure qui
n'aura pas d'impact sur l'économie je
souhaite que le Sénat au diapason de
l'Assemblée nationale puisse donner une
majorité en faveur d'une mesure qui est
une mesure de bon sens prise en d'autres
temps dont on doit s'instruire des bons
effets et et des conditions
d'application dans le passé mais qui
sera surtout utile à No concitoyen et
utile à l'emploi je vous remercie merci
monsieur le ministre dans la suite de la
discussion la parole est à Madame emerie
dum rapporteur de la commission des
affaires
sociales monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre madame la présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales mes
chers collègues c'est dans un contexte
tout à fait particulier que nous sommes
appelés aujourd'hui à examiner cette
proposition de loi visant à autoriser le
déblocage exceptionnel de
l'intéressement et de la participation
adopté par l'Assemblée nationale le 13
mai
dernier au terme de 3 ans de dégradation
continue les dépenses de consommation
des ménages et le pouvoir d'achat de nos
concitoyens ont en effet établi l'an
dernier de tristes records les chiffres
publiés par l'INS la semaine dernière
sont en effet sans appel en 2012 les
ménages ont réduit leur consommation et
ce pour la seconde fois seulement depuis
l'après-guerre et pour la première fois
depuis
1993 le pouvoir d'achat individuel quant
à lui a connu l'an dernier sa plus forte
baisse depuis 30 ans si la crise que
nous traversons se mesure à l'ône des
données de l'INC elle se traduit aussi
et surtout par les difficultés
financières que rencontrent nos
concitoyens et par le désarroi que
dissimule de plus en plus mal nos
administrer la mesure de déblocage sur
laquelle nous allons nous prononcer vise
au moment où la conjoncture reste
difficile à compléter la stratégie de
croissance du gouvernement en améliorant
dans les meilleurs délais le pouvoir
d'achat des Français et en soutenant la
consommation des ménages
elle ouvre aux salariés concernés la
possibilité de récupérer avant le délai
légal de déblocage qui peut-être de 5 ou
de 8 ans les revenus épargnés au titre
de la participation et de
l'intéressement et leur permet de
bénéficier des avantages sociaux et
fiscaux habituellement associé à
l'épargne
salariale je tiens à rappeler qu'une
telle mesure ne constitue pas une idée
neuve ce dispositif a même été
abondamment utilisé par les
gouvernements
successifs depuis 198
pas moins de qu déblocages exceptionnels
ont ainsi été autorisés par la loi en
1996 2004 et 2008 5 même si l'on compte
le déblocage réalisé en 2005 qui à la
différence des autres n'offrait aucune
exonération fiscale au bénéficiaaires
des droits
libérés le dispositif que nous examinons
aujourd'hui se distingue néanmoins de
l'ensemble de ses
prédécesseurs il est à la fois plus
ambitieux d'un spectre plus large ce qui
doit garantir son efficacité et mieux
encadré ce qui devrait limiter les
effets indésirables souvent attachés à
ce type de
mesure il couvre ainsi les sommes issues
de la participation et de
l'intéressement quand les dispositifs
précédents en particulier ceux de 2005
et 2008 ne concernaient que le premier
régime c'est-à-dire la
participation ce choix permet ainsi de
toucher les entreprises de plus de 50
sal pour lesquels la participation
constitue une obligation mais aussi les
PME et certaines très petites
entreprises qui recourt plus facilement
aux accords d'intéressement contte tenu
de leur facilité de mise en
œuvre il permet également aux salariés
de débloquer l'ensemble des sommes qui
leur ont été attribuées au titre de la
participation et de l'intéressement quel
que soit leur année de versement et
l'exercice au titre duquel elles ont été
attribuées les sommes déblocables ne
sont pas limité à celle attribué au
cours des deux années précédentes comme
ce fut le cas en 1994 et en
1995 il autorise enfin le bénéficiaire à
débloquer jusqu'à 20000 € soit le double
du plafond autorisé en 2004 ou en 2008
permettant ainsi de procéder comme vous
l'avez indiqué Monsieur le Ministre à
l'achat d'un véhicule ou à la
réalisation de travaux domestiques
conséquents si ce dispositif est
ambitieux il concerne en effet
potentiellement près de 8000 million de
salariés et 90 milliards en cours il
reste néanmoins fermement encadré afin
de limiter les effets pervers associé
par le passé au déblocage
anticipés le dispositif exclut d'abord
les sommes issues de la participation et
de l'intéressement investi dans les
plans d'épargne pour la retraite
collectif Les PERCO afin de ne pas
remettre en cause l'épargne longue qui
permet de compléter la pension de
retraite de salariés souvent modeste il
exclut ensuite
les sommes placées dans des fonds
solidaires les 2,6 milliards en cours
consacrés au financement des entreprises
sociales et solidairire sont en effet
indispensables à la pérennité de ces
structures il propose enfin des
modalités particulière pour le déblocage
des sommes affectées à l'actionnariat
salarié si le déblocage des sommes
investit sur des fonds monétaires ou
diversifié peut se faire sans formalité
préalable sur simple demande du salarié
celui des droits affectés à
l'acquisition de titre de l'entreprise
ou à l'acquisition de part de fond
commun placement d'actionnariat salarié
et quant à lui conditionner à la
signature d'un accord
collectif le texte prend ainsi toutes
les précautions nécessaires pour ne pas
fragiliser inutilement les fonds propres
des entreprises
concernées ces précautions ont
d'ailleurs été considérablement renforcé
par nos collègues députés à l'occasion
de l'examen de la proposition de loi par
l'Assemblée nationale
à l'initiative du rapporteur de la
commission des affaires sociales
monsieur Richard Ferrand l'assemblée a
en particulier complété le dispositif
initial en conditionnant expressément le
déblocage à l'achat d'un ou plusieurs
biens ou à la fourniture d'une ou
plusieurs prestations de
services ce faisant la proposition de
loi vise à éviter que les sommes
débloqué ne soi immédiatement redirigé
vers d'autres supports d'épargne en
particulier les livr défiscalisé dont
les plafonds ont récemment été
augmentés ce fléchage est d'autant plus
nécessaire que ce phénomène a jusqu'ici
considérablement amoindri l'effet des
mesures de déblocage sur la consommation
des ménages 70 % des sommes liées à la
participation ou à l'intéressement
débloqué en 2004 auraiit été selon l'INC
immédiatement replacé sur des supports
d'épargne plus liquides ou plus
rémunérateurs afin de garantir
l'efficacité du fléchage l'assemblée a
également prévu une procédure de
contrôle
allégée imposant au salariés
bénéficiaaires de la mesure de tenir à
la disposition de l'administration les
pièces justificatives attestant de
l'usage des sommes
débloquées ce mécanisme me paraît
équilibré il a le mérite d'être
suffisamment simple pour ne pas
décourager les salariés désireux de
bénéficier du déblocage tout en étant
suffisamment clair pour décourager les
abus
en guise de conclusion je tiens à faire
part de mes regrets concernant le rejet
de cette proposition de loi par la
commission des affaires sociales jeudi
dernier nous sommes tous conscients dans
cet hémicycle que cette mesure de
déblocage ne permettra pas à elle seul
ni de faire brusquement décoller la
consommation dans ce pays ni de rétablir
définitivement la confiance de nos
concitoyens dans l'avenir mais je reste
persuadé qu'elle pourra constituer pour
ceux qui pourront en bénéficier en tout
cas une mesure bienvenue au moment où
les effets des réformes structurelles
menées par le gouvernement au cours des
12 derniers mois commencent à peine à se
faire sentir je vous remercie de votre
attention merci Madame
rapporteur la parole dans la suite de la
discussion générale est à madame
Isabelle Debré pour le groupe
UMP
président
monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre madame le rapporteur ou la
rapporteur mes chers collègues le 28
mars dernier le président de la
République François Hollande annoncé un
déblocage exceptionnel de la
participation afin disait-il de relancer
la
consommation cette volonté s'est
traduite par une proposition de loi du
groupe socialiste de l'Assemblée
nationale adopté le 13 mai
dernier permettez-moi ici d'exprimer
deux regrets le premier que le support
législatif retenu ne soit pas un projet
de loi qui aurait permis au
parlementaires de disposer d'une étude
d'impact et le second de ne pas avoir
attendu monsieur le ministre vous le
rappeliez tout à l'heure les travaux du
copiésas avant de prendre une telle
initiative copias je le rappelle qui a
été créé ici même au Sénat notre
commission des affaires sociales a rej
jeté ce texte la semaine dernière
démontrant une fois encore l'absence
d'unité au sein de la majorité
sénatoriale je tiens tout d'abord à
souligner mes chers collègues qu'en 2004
et 2008 lors que les gouvernements
précédents avaient proposé les mêmes
mesur que celles sur lesquelles nous
aurons à nous prononcer aujourd'hui la
gauche s'y était fermement opposée à cet
égard permettez-moi de rappeler
quelquesuns des propos tenus à l'époque
sur les bans social e de notre haute
assemblée notre collègue Jean-Pierre
gaefroid lors de l'examen de la loi du 3
décembre 2008 en faveur des revenus du
travail voyez dans le déblocage de la
participation je le cite un grand
classique des périodes de ralentissement
de l'économie
ou encore et je dirais même mieux encore
un montage trompeur pour les salariés
destinés à masquer l'inefficacité de la
politique du gouvernement je cite notre
ancien collègue Raymond le textier
s'exclamit faire passer une baisse de
l'épargne pour une augmentation du
pouvoir d'achat il fallait
osé quant à Madame brick aujourd'hui
ministre je rappelle qu'elle avait
déclaré que le déblocage et toujours je
cite que le déblocage de la
participation était un très mauvais
signal donné à l'épargne
salariale je m'arrête là la
démonstration est en fait que les
convictions de l'opposition d'alors
devenu majorité depuis ne sont guerre
établis en matière de déblocage de
l'épargne
salariale je tiens pour ma part à
rappeler comme je l'avais fait en 2008
lors de l'examen du projet de loi en
faveur des revenus du travail que la
participation et l'intéressement ne
peuvent être considérés comme des
variables d'ajustement de la politique
économique en tant que Gauliste il me
semble utile de rappeler en quelques
mots l'origine de la participation et et
surtout sa
vocation mise en uvre par le général de
Gaulle sur la proposition de Louis
vallon Marcel Loichot et René
Capitan la participation avait
clairement pour objectif la
réconciliation entre le capital et le
travail et comme le disait le Général
l'association des hommes de leurs
intérêts de leurs
capacités la participation permet
d'associer les salariés au résultats de
l'entreprise en leur attribuant une
partie du bénéfice réaliste
elle ne constitue en aucun cas comme
certains voudraient le faire croire
souvent par mes connaissances voire
peut-être par dogmatisme une
substitution de
salaire cette proposition de loi qui
vise à redonner du pouvoir d'achat aux
Français en autorisant le déblocage des
avoirs qui détiennent au titre de la
participation et de
l'intéressement cherche bien
maladroitement à Pier les conséquences
d'une politique économique et sociale
inadaptée à la situation que conna notre
pays depuis mai 2012 vous n'avez cessé
monsieur le ministre vous et votre
gouvernement d'alourdir les prélèvements
qui pèsent fortement sur les classes
moyennes matraqué par une fiscalité
devenue
confiscatoire depuis mai 2012 vous
n'avez cessé de défaire la politique en
faveur du travail mené par le précédent
gouvernement je pense en particulier à
la défiscalisation des heures supplément
qui permettait aux salariés d'accroîre
substantiellement leur pouvoir
d'achat pour la première fois depuis
1984 année où vous étiez déjà aux
affaires le pouvoir d'achat des Français
a reculé en 2012 l'INC évoque un recul
du pouvoir d'achat de -04 % imputable
selon lui à la forte hausse des impôts à
notre grand regret la seule mesure que
vous préconisez pour remplir le
porte-monnaie bien allégé des Français
est celle qui avait été mise en œuvre en
2008 et qui n'a il faut bien le
reconnaître produit les les effets
escomptés des études portant sur les
mesures de déblocage de 2004 et 2008 ont
été réalisés s'intéressant notamment aux
usages fait des sommes
débloquées selon une étude de l'INC daté
de
2005 les 2 tiers des retraits effectués
en 2004 étaient aller vers des
placements plus souples comme le livra
ou des placements plus rémunérateurs
comme l'assurance vie à titre d'exemple
sur les 7 milliards dégagés en 2004 à
peine 2 milliards avaient été injectés
dans des consommations nouvelles ces 7
milliards dégagés ne représentaient
d'ailleurs qu'un diè de l'encours de
l'épargne salariale en
2008 1,6 million de salariés avaient
retiré au total 3 millions milliard 9
d'euros bien loin de l'objectif
recherché 12 milliards
d'euros j'ajoute que la mesure que vous
proposez aura un coût fiscal pour l'État
dans la mesure où les déblocages seront
exonérés d'impôts ou tout du moins un
manque à gagner fiscal il ne s'agit
finalement que d'un simple effet
d'annonce qui n'aura aucun impact
positif sur le pouvoir d'achat et qui
remet sur le devant de la scène le myth
éternel pourrais-je dire de la relance
de la croissance par la consommation
croyez-vous réellement qu'en temps de
crise je rappelle que la France est en
récession les Français l'intention
d'affecter les avoirs retirés à la
consommation des biens et des services
il faudrait d'abord monsieur le ministre
restaurer la confiance pour que nos
concitoyens consomment mais aussi lutter
plus efficacement en faveur de l'emploi
et du développement des
entreprises contte tenu de la situation
dans laquelle se trouve notre pays les
Français s'abstiendront de retirer leurs
avoirs ou placeront les sommes
débloquées sur un livra par exemple qui
a un profil plus liquide en outre vous
souhaitez permettre le déblocage de
20000 €. alors même que la moyenne d'un
compte déparne salarial vous le savez
est de 7500 €. aussi nous proposerons un
amendement abaissant le plafond de
déblocage à 10000 €. un deuxième
amendement que je vous présenterai vise
à débloquer ne débloquer que les sommes
placées en fonds monétaire afin de ne
pas agrver excessivement le budget des
entreprises je tiens également à
souligner que les travaux de l'Assemblée
nationale ont introduit de la complexité
dans le dispositif de déblocage pour
obliger nos concitoyens à consommer et
non à
épargner à la suite de l'adoption d'un
amendement du rapporteur il a été décidé
que le salarié doit pouvoir tenir à la
disposition de l'administration fiscale
toutes les pièces justificatives
attestant l'usage de toutes les sommes
débloquées nos collègues étaient-ils
conscients qu'une telle mesure est tout
simplement inapplicable tant pour le
salarié que pour les contrôleurs nous
proposerons un amendement visant à
simplifier le contrôle en confiant au
teneur de compte la tâche de la gestion
administrative je vous présenterai cet
amendement auprès de l'administration
fiscale monsieur le ministre nous sommes
sans illusion sur les effets du réel du
déblocage de la participation et de
l'intéressement sur la consommation
avec ce dispositif vous voulez nous
faire croire que vous pouvez relancer la
consommation par le pouvoir d'achat
c'est une fausse bonne idée et
malheureusement les expériences passées
même sous le précédent gouvernement
auquel j'appartenais l'ont
démontré enfin un dernier argument alors
que la prochaine réforme des retraites
doit être engagée rapidement et qu'un
allongement de la durée de cotisation se
profil quel peut-être l'intérêt des
salariés a liquider aujourd'hui leur
épargne longue et ne devraiton pas au
contraire inciter nos concitoyens à
préparer de façon sereine leur retraite
grâce à ces différents dispositifs
d'épargne salarial pour ces raisons et à
défaut de prise en compte des
amendements défendus par notre groupe
nous nous opposerons au texte qui nous
est proposé je vous remercie merci chers
collègues la parole est maintenant à
Dominique vin pour le groupe CRC
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre madame la rapporteur mes chers
collègues notre pays souffre depuis des
années de politiques d'austérité qui
conduisent à une forte modération des
salaires cette politique de rigueur
publique comme privé entraîne notre pays
nous le pensons dans une spirale
récessionniste comme l' teste les
restantes récente statistique de l'INC
la consommation des ménages a d'ailleurs
reculé de 0,9 % entre février 2012 et
février 2013 et cette chute n'est
malheureusement pas accidentelle c'est
la démonstration d'un changement de
comportement radical de la part des
consommateurs qui face à l'ampleur de la
crise ne font plus seulement le choix de
privilégier les achats les moins chers
en joant sur les sols les promotions en
achetant en ligne il décide maintenant
de renoncer àet soit par prudence soit
parce qu'ils sont dans l'incapacité
financière de le faire l'explosion du
chômage que vous refuser d'encadrer en
interdisant les licenciements boursiers
les salaires indécents soutenus par les
exonérations de cotisation social
consenti au patron pour les salaires les
plus bas la hausse des contrats
précaires et à temps partiel tout cela
converge vers une baisse continue de la
demande et de la consommation pourtant
chacun s'accorde à dire qu'elle aura
inévitablement pour conséquence
l'accroissement du chômage et comme le
précisait l'économiste Philippe léger
tout est en place pour que l'échec se
perpétue en 2014 je le cite le PCT de
compétitivité sera financé par des
coupes budgétaires supplémentaire et par
une hausse de la TVA ce qui aggravera la
baisse de la consommation fin de
citation et c'est aussi sans compter sur
les conséquences à venir de l'Anille et
de l'article 12 de la loi de
transposition qui aorise les employeurs
à baisser la rémunération de leurs
salariés jusqu'à 1,2 SMIC voire à les
licenciés si ces derniers refusent cette
atteinte à leur pouvoir d'achat comment
croire un seul instant que ces mesures
qui vont soit compresser les salaires
soit entraîné des vagues de licenciement
n'auront pas de conséquen désastreuses
sur l'emploi et la
consommation c'est dans ce contexte que
nous sommes appelés à débattre de cette
proposition de loi qui prévoit le
déblocage de l'intéressement et de la
participation cette proposition nous
apparaît limitée tout d'abord il ne
s'agit là que d'une mesure à un coout et
donc limité dans le temps passer les 6
mois durant lesquels les salariés
pourront prétendre au déblocage de
l'intéressement et de la participation
le gouvernement s'il ne trouve pas
d'autres moyens d'action pour soutenir
la consommation ne disposera d'aucun
levier supplémentaire pour relancer
l'économie et personne ne peut
raisonnablement prétendre aujourd'hui
que les conséquences catastrophiques des
politiques menées depuis des années qui
malheureusement se poursuivent pourrai
être contrebalancé par cette seule
mesure en 2014 lorsque les délais
d'application de cette loi seront clos
comment entendez-vous monsieur le
ministre permettre aux salariés de notre
pays de consommer qui plus ait des
produits de qualité fabriqués en France
quand les Français sont déjà des
millions à renoncer aux soins faute
d'argent que le nombre de salariés
pauvres ne cesse de croître nous doutons
d'autant plus de l'efficacité de cette
mesure qu'elle suppose que toutes les
sommes débloquées par les salariés
soient réinvesties dans la consommation
si j'admets que plus de 8 millions de
salariés sont concernés nous ne pouvons
ignorer ni les expériences malheureuses
du passé ni le contexte actuel on sait
en effet grâce à une étude de l'UNC
menée à la suite du déblocage de
l'intéressement mis en œuvre en 2004 que
sur les 7,5 milliards d'euros débloqués
par les salariés au mieux de ,5
milliards d'euros ont été réinjectés
dans la consommation on le sait les
salariés ont fait très majoritairement
le choix de placer ces sommes sur
d'autres supports d'épargne plus souple
et pouvant être mobilisés par la suite
plus facilement or compte tenu de
l'effet anxiogène de la crise économique
tout nous conduit à penser que les
salariés auront aujourd'hui le même
comportement qu'en 2004 et en 2008 et ce
d'autant plus que cette disposition
intervient après que le gouvernement ait
fait le choix de rehausser le plafond du
livr a placement préféré de nos
concitoyens ceci étant dit c'est ce qui
nous intéresse particulièrement avec
cette proposition de loi on voit bien
que les députés socialistes tout comme
le président de la République et le
gouvernement donneent raison à l'analyse
qui est la nôtre depuis maintenant
plusieurs années selon laquelle la
relance économique de notre pays passe
aussi
par une relance de la consommation c'est
la raison pour laquelle nous nous
abstiendrons sur ce texte en invitant le
gouvernement aller beaucoup plus loin
comment d'ailleurs ici ne pas exprimer
notre déception suite à l'annonce faite
par le ministre de l'économie et des
finances de ne pas légiférer afin
d'encadrer les rémunérations des
dirigeants d'entreprise en lieu et place
d'une loi le gouvernement dit avoir
obtenu de la présidente du mdeef
Laurence Pariso et du président de de la
FEP Pierre Pringuet un renforcement de
leur code de gouvernance c'est-à-dire
que vous faites le choix d'une très
hypothétique autorégulation des patrons
et des actionnaires à celui de
l'efficacité d'une loi vous auriez mieux
fait de vous inspirer notre proposition
de loi du 21 mai 2012 tendant à encadrer
les écarts de rémunération au sein des
entreprises publiques et pririvé
celle-ci permettrait de relever les
salaires les plus bas puisque toute
décision ayant pour effet
de porter le montant annuel de la
rémunération la plus élevée dans un
écart dépassant le rapport 1 à 20 serait
considéré comme nul dès lors que le
salaire le plus bas ne serait pas relevé
voilà une mesure qui permettrait n'en
doutons pas d'augmenter le pouvoir
d'achat notre conviction monsieur le
ministre c'est qu'il faut rompre
définitivement avec toutes les
politiques budgétaires et salariale
récessive en mettant en place une
stratégie de croissance conjugant
relance de de l'offre et relance de la
demande en soumettant la finance pour
favoriser
l'investissement productif car en fait
de quelle crise parlons-nous de la crise
d'un système économique le capitalisme
qui conduit notre pays dans le mur en
accaparant les richesses économique de
la planète en mettant sous santion les
salariés voire en les appauvrissant où
est d'ailleurs la crise pour les
actionnaires du CAC 40 CAC 40 qui se
sont arrangés depuis 2008 pour
stabiliser les dividendes distribuées à
un très haut niveau en faisant des
salariés les variables d'ajustement de
la crise n'est-ce pas le Figaro qui
annonçait il y a moins d'un mois que le
groupe lagardaire allait distribuer 1,2
milliards d'euros de dividend
exceptionnel à ses actionnaires soit
près de deux fois le montant de la taxe
imposée à partir de cette année au
retraité imposable de quel crise
parle-ton lorsque le journal Les Échos
j'ai de bonne lecture indique dans son
édition du 2 mai 2013 il y a donc très
peu de temps je cite l'abondance de
liquidité et la recherche de rendement
pousse les investisseurs vers les
actions décidément ce texte ne va pas
assez loin il faut monsieur le ministre
de toute autre ambition pour que notre
pays retrouve le chemin du dynamisme
économique et de la justice sociale et
c'est pourquoi le groupe CRC
s'abstiendra sur ce
texte merci chers collègues la parole
est à Monsieur Hervé Marseille pour le
groupe
udiuc monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre madame la rapporteur mes chers
collègues la manière dont ce texte a été
présenté examiné en commission des
affaires sociales démontre bien ses
limites madame la rapporteur vous l'avez
dit en commission et vous l'avez répété
tout à l'heure la mesure ne permettra ni
de faire décoller la consommation dans
le pays ni de rétablir la confiance
autre citation la mesure ne constitue
pas une une idée neuve c'est un constat
et enfin il s'agit d'une mesure
circonstantielle qui appelle des
réformes plus profondes de notre système
d'épargne salarial là aussi vous l'avez
rappelé tout à l'heure on pourrait
presque s'arrêter là puisque tout est
dit et rien d'étonnant dans ces
conditions à ce que le texte a été
rejeté par notre not re commission alors
reprenons ces différents points l'objet
du texte qui nous est soumis est de
permettre aux salariés de débloquer leur
prime de participation et
d'intéressement dans la limite de 20000
€ avant le terme du blocage légal en
bénéficiant des exonérations fiscales et
sociales qui leur sont attachés afin de
consommer des biens et des services
effectivement il ne s'agit pas là d'une
mesure particulièrement innovante
d'autres gouvernements l'ont fait
auparavant comme cela a déjà été rappelé
la loi a autorisé cinq déblocages
exceptionnel en 20 ans c'est presque
devenu un classique on ne peut donc pas
vous reprocher monsieur le ministre
d'avoir agi comme vos prédécesseurs mais
en revanche on pourrait vous reprocher
de ne pas avoir tiré les leçons des
démarches précédentes l'objet de la
mesure est de relancer la consommation
alors on peut se poser trois questions
la première est-ce que la mesure sera
effectivement utile et de nature à
relancer la consommation à l'évidence
non on ne saurait mieux le dire que
notre rapporteur en dépit de son ampleur
potentielle l'effec késien du déblocage
exceptionnel ne peut avoir à lui seul
qu'un impact marginal marginal est
d'autant plus incertain que l'on ne sait
rien des montants débloqué en 2004 2006
et 2008 heureusement le présent texte
prévoit enfin une évaluation à
postériori enfin nous y verront plus
clair mais l'information ne sera
exploitable que pour l'avenir la mesure
aura d'autant moins de chance de
relancer la consommation que l'ensemble
des autres mesures que le Gouvernement a
prise depuis son arrivée au pouvoir ne
peut au contraire que la déprimer c'est
c'est le cas de la suppression de
l'exonération des heures supplémentaires
de l'augmentation de la CSG de la
suppression du forfait applicable au
versement des cotisations social pour
les salariés intervenants au domicile
des particuliers du gel du barê de
l'impôt sur le revenu et enfin de
l'augmentation de la redevance
audioovisuel ce sont ces 30 milliards
d'euros retirés au pouvoir d'achat des
ménages qui contribuent à maintenir la
consommation en berne et apparemment ce
n'est pas fini puisque on parle d'une
augmentation de la TVA qui serait prévue
pour le 1er janvier 2014 sans doute
aussi la mise sous conditions de
ressources des allocations familiales
comment alors espérer quoi que ce soit
du présent texte c'est en réalité toute
la cohérence de votre politique
économique du pouvoir d'achat et de la
consommation qui est posée et de manière
particulièrement caricaturale lorsque
l'on met en balance le déblocage
exceptionnel proposé avec le quasi
triplement du forfait social dans le
tout premier collectif budgétaire adopté
par la nouvelle majorité en juillet 2012
il est totalement contradictoire de
faire passer il y a moins d'un an le
forfait social de 8 à 20 % pour je cite
éviter la substitution de cette forme de
rénumération au hausse de salairire
direct et maintenant compter sur la
participation et l'intéressement pour
relancer la consommation ce qui me
conduit à la seconde question soulevée
par la proposition faut-il seulement
relancer la consommation ainsi à notre
avis non parce que ce qui affecte notre
économie est un choc d'offre et non de
demande c'est le chômage le poids des
prélèvements sociaux l'insuffisance
d'investissement qui déprime la
croissance et partant le pouvoir d'achat
des ménages dans ces conditions lancer
la consommation ne peut être d'aucune
efficacité pour faire repartir la
croissance autrement dit dans ces
conditions le multiplicateur kénésien ne
peut-être que faible voire nul au
contraire même le déblocage s'il était
effectivement utilisé par les salariés
pourrait déstabiliser la trésorerie des
entreprises et pardon fragiliser leurs
fonds propres et ce à un moment où au
contraire il faudrait les renforcer
notre économie manquant cruellement
d'investissement productifs compte tenu
de ces éléments le fait que le déblocage
proposé soit d'une ampleur sans
précédent n'est pas une bonne nouvelle
et c'est vrai qu'il sera d'une ampleur
sans précédent ceux de 1994 et 1996 ne
concernit que l'achat de véhicules et
les déblocages étaient limités aux
sommes attribué au cours des deux années
précédentes quand celui-ci un objet de
consommation beaucoup plus large pour
des sommes nonlmitées dans le temps le
plafond de déblocage en 2004 et 2008
était deux fois inférieur à celui
proposé aujourd'hui et contrairement à
celle-ci les mesures de 2005 et et 2008
ne concernaient que la participation et
non l'intéressement l'ampleur
potentielle de la mesure fait donc bien
peser un risque sur notre économie ce
qui en résumé nous conduit à penser qu'à
l'échelle macro-économique au mieux ce
déblocage ne servira à rien et au pire
qu'il pourrait même avoir des effets
négatifs et à l'échelle micro-économique
est on seulement sûr que les sommes
débloquées soient injectées dans la
consommation c'est la troisième question
selon nous posée par ce texte autrement
dit n'y a-t-il pas un risque de
détournement de la mesure nos collègues
de l'Assemblée nationale ont adopté deux
dispositions pour l'éviter si
l'effectivité de la première nous paraît
parfaitement illusoire la seconde va en
revanche dans le bon sens mais
mériterait selon nous d'être encore
resserrée la première de ces
dispositions institue un contrôle à
postériori les bénéficiaires de la
mesure devront tenir à disposition de
l'administration fiscale les pièces
justificati àestant de l'usage des
sommes débloquées mais qui peut croire
une seule seconde que de tels contrôles
seront effectués comme si
l'administration fiscale n'avait déjà
pas suffisamment à faire avec ses
missions actuelles en revanche les
députés ont été bien irit de limiter
l'usage des sommes débloquées à la
fourniture de services ou l'achat de
biens il s'agit d'éviter le
contournement de la mesure consistante à
replacer les sommes débloquées sur des
supports d'épargne plus liquides ou plus
rénumérateurs risque aujourd'hui
d'autant plus réel que les plafonds des
livretes défiscalisé ont été récemment
augmentés même en l'absence de contrôle
à postériori effectif nous croyons que
l'immense majorité des salariés qui
onuront recours au dispositif
respecteront les règles du jeu en
revanche nous pensons que le dispositif
doit encore être resserré pour pour ne
concerner que la fourniture de services
à l'exception donc de l'achat de biens
manufacturés nous défendrons donc et
vous l'avez évoqué monsieur le ministre
un amendement en ce sens c'est mon
collègue Jean-Marie van lonberg qui va
le faire tout à
l'heure parce que le déblocage
représenterait une perte de valeur
économique s'il servait surtout à
acheter des biens produits à l'étranger
et donc à dégrader un peu plus la
balance commerciale française en
revanche la mesure pourrait au moins
être à minima un premier geste en
direction des secteurs du bâtiment et
des services à la personne c'est-à-dire
d'activités non délocalisables qui ont
vraiment besoin d'être soutenu pour
développer leur potentiel en attendant
la remise en plat de tout le dispositif
d'intéressement de participation et
d'actiononnariat salarié promis par
Monsieur le Président de la République à
rueille le 29 novembre 2012 le groupe
udiuc se positionnera sur ce texte en
fonction du sort qui sera réservé à nos
amendements mais je crain monsieur le
ministre que vous n'z déjà déjà apporté
la réponse avant même qu'il soit défendu
merci de votre attention merci chers
collègues la parole est à monsieur Yvon
Collin pour le groupe
RDSE
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues sur un
sujet aussi important qui traite du
pouvoir d'achat de nos
concitoyens dans une période de crise
économique que nous traversons les
divisions partisanes et les renvois
mutuels de responsabilité non me
semble-t-il pas lieu d'être car le sujet
mérite le plus grand sérieux et je vous
invite donc mes chers collègues de la
majorité comme opposition à rassembler
nos efforts pour permettre à nos
concitoyens les plus en difficulté de
sortir la tête de l'eau si je puis
m'exprimer ainsi faut-il rappeler les
chiffres annoncés récemment par l'INC un
recul du pouvoir d'achat de 09 % chiffre
jamais atteint depuis
1984 et une baisse de 04 % de la
consommation en 2012 sans compter la
récession - 02 % de croissance qui se
poursuit pour le 2e trimestre consécutif
les causes de cette situation sont
multiples et embriqué de manière
complexe et les responsabilités sont
sans doute très largement partagé en
premier lieu s'explique par le
ralentissement des revenus d'activité
l'augmentation du chômage qui sont les
conséquences directes de la crise
mondiale qui a plongé notre pays et bien
d'autres bien sûr dans une langueur sans
précédente bien sûr les Hauses d'impôts
jouent également un rôle dans la
perception qu'on les Français leur
pouvoir d'achat mais c'est c'est aussi
l'augmentation des dépenses
contrait qui pèse lourdement sur le
budget logement énergie téléphonie ces
dépenses qui représentaient 15 %
seulement de la consommation des ménages
en
1959 et qui représente aujourd'hui 30 %.
le moral des ménages est au plus bas il
y a urgence à rétablir monsieur le
ministre leur confiance dans notre
économie la proposition de loi que nous
examinons aujourd'hui il contribuera
sans doute elle sera en tout cas un
apport non négligeable pour nombre de
ménages qui pourront débloquer jusqu'à
20000 € sur les montants qui le sont
attribués dans le cadre de la
participation et de l'intéressement ces
montants qui doivent normalement être
bloqué pendant 5 à 8 ans pourront donc
être débloqués de manière anticipée dans
la plupart des cas sur simple demande du
bénéficiaire entre le 1er juillet et le
31 décembre 2013 certes cette
proposition de loi ne permettra pas à
elle seule ça a été dit je le redis de
dynamiser durablement le pouvoir d'achat
et la croissance mais n'en constitue pas
moins sans doute un coup de pouce
bienvenu pour de nombreux ménages et
viendra s'inscrire dans un dispositif
plus large monsieur le ministre nous l'a
dit c'est ainsi qu'elle devra être
complétée par d'autres mesures en faveur
du pouvoir d'achat et l'examen
prochainement du projet de loi relatif à
la consommation monsieur le ministre en
sera sans doute l'occasion relancer la
croissance c'est relancer la
consommation l'investissement mais c'est
aussi et surtout agir pour la
compétitivité de nos entreprises nous
l'avons suffisamment dit les marches de
nos entreprises ont atteint un niveau
dangereux ement faible qui les empêche
d'investir qui les empêche d'innover
résultats sont pris dans un cercle
vicieux et leur retard de compétitivité
vis-à-vis de la concurrence étrangère
s'accroit le gouvernement et la majorité
pas toujours au complet je le regrette
ont déjà engager un certain nombre de
réformes courageuses et nécessaires pour
permettre à nos entreprises de retrouver
une réelle compétitivité coûte et hors
coûte et notre groupe lui a les à toutes
soutenu qui s'agisse de la banque
publique d'investissement ou du crédit
d'impôt compétitivité emploi et le CIC
et c'est grâce à un ensemble de réformes
structurelles de ce type que nous
pourrons sans doute restaurer une
croissance durable et créatrice d'emploi
et c'est pourquoi les efforts en ce sens
doivent être poursuivis et accélérés car
la croissance et les emplois sont les
meilleures garanties pour le pouvoir
d'achat des Français et de ce point de
vue le rapport Galois doit être notre
référence absolue et nous sommes heureux
que le gouvernement monsieur le ministre
l'ai compris en attendant que ces
réformes produisent leurs effets la
présente proposition de loi portant des
blocages exceptionnel de la
participation et de l'intéressement est
une mesure importante souple et efficass
pour restaurer en partie le pouvoir
d'achat de nos concitoyens en incluant
les sommes
inclus les sommes issu pardon de
l'intéressement et non seulement c'est
issu de la participation comme c'était
le cas dans les deux derniers
dispositifs de déblocage en 2005 et 2008
la présente proposition de loi élargit
le bénéfice de cette mesure qui
concernera plus largement les salariés
des PME et non seulement ceux des
grandes entreprises certes j'entends les
critiques de nos collègues de
l'opposition qui nous disent que ce type
de disposition n'a jamais marché et
provoque surtout des effets d'obè je
leur répondrai que le dispositif tel
qu'il a été amélioré à l'Assemblée
nationale permet justement selon moi en
tout cas d'éviter ce type d'effet ainsi
l'article 1er prévoit le fléchage des
sommes débloquées vers l'acquisition de
biens de consommation ou de prestation
de servicicees ce fléchage évitera que
les sommes débloquées ne soi pas dé pass
vers d'autres types d'épargne plus
liquide ou plus rémunératrices comme
cela a pu être le cas par le passé et
pour éviter les abus sans être rigide et
risque d'courager les bénéficiaires la
proposition de loi également prévu un
dispositif de contrôle par
l'administration fiscale certes je
partage moi aussi avec certains
collègues quelques interrogations
concernant l'application pratique de ce
dispositif de contrôle en effet si les
bénéficiaires n'effectuent qu'un achat
important grâce aux sommes débloqués
cela semble relativement simple de
garder à disposition de l'administration
fiscale les pièces justifiant cet achat
mais qu'en est-il lorsqu'ils effectuent
de multiples achat de moindre montant et
il paraît dès lors assez complexe de
conserver l'ensemble des tiquets de
caisse et autres preuves d'achat et
cette comp cette complication ne me
paraît pas néanmoins de nature en tout
cas je l'espère a constitué un véritable
obstacle à l'efficacité et à l'utilité
de ce t de ce texte mais peut-être
monsieur le ministre nous répondra sur
ce point ce déblocage exceptionnel ne
constitue pas non plus une menace
déstabilisatrice pour les entreprises
comme je l'ai entendu car il est
suffisamment encadré par la loi et un
certain nombre de précautions ont été
prises par les auteurs du texte ainsi
quand les fonds bloqués sont réinvestis
dans les titres d'entreprise ou dans
Lespart ou action d'OPC VM la conclusion
d'un accord collectif est nécessaire
pour les débloquer et cela permettra de
ne pas dstabiliser la trésorerie ou les
fonds propres des entreprises outre les
fonds investis dans des entreprises
solidaires sont exclus du dispositif ça
a été rappelé ce qui permet de péréniser
le financement de ces dernières et par
conséquent cette proposition de loi
monsieur le ministre nous semble aussi
utile qu'équilibrée elle prévoit un
certain nombre de gardefous pour éviter
un effet tout effet secondaire non
désiré non désiré tout en restant
suffisamment souple pour être efficasse
elle constituera nous le pensons en tout
cas vraiment une bouffée d'oxygène pour
de nombreux ménages qui se privent
depuis plusieurs mois et n'osent pas
consommer et voter en faveur de cette
loi c'est soutenir le pouvoir d'achat de
nos concitoyens ils en ont bien besoin
en ce moment et c'est pourquoi avec mes
collègues radicaux de gauche et les
membres du RDSE nous la soutiendrons
dans une belle unanimité je vous
remercie de votre attention merci chers
collègues la parole est à Monsieur Jean
Desessard pour le groupe
écologie
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre madame la rapporteur chers
collègues que nous disent les textes à
propos de la participation de
l'intéressement ils nous disent qu'ils
ont pour objet d'associer collectivement
les salariés au résultats et au
performance de leurs
entreprises les primes de participation
et d'intéressement ne sont donc pas
versé aux salariés en contrepartie du
travail fourni au profit de l'employeur
elles le sont en raison de
l'appartenance du salarié à l'entreprise
et de ses résultats et vousvez
d'ailleurs noté monsieur le ministre
l'inégalité
entre les grandes entreprises enfin les
salariés des grandes entreprises et les
salariés des petites entreprises et pour
nous écologistes la reconnaissance de
l'appartenance du salarié à l'entreprise
ne doit pas simplement passer par des
mécanismes de prime elle doit également
passer par une meilleure intégration des
salariés au choix et aux orientations de
l'entreprise qu'en est-il du droit à
l'information ou au contrôle direct ou
indirect qu'on les salariés sur leur
entreprise où en est-on dans la mise en
œuvre des dispositifs qui permettent une
meilleure coopération des salariés aux
orientations de leur entreprise qu'en
est-il de une véritable codécision dans
le dialogue social et voici une question
qui reste encore à résoudre lorsqu'on
parle de participation et
d'intéressement à cet égard je rappelle
que les sociétés coopératives ouvrières
de production les SCOP dans
lesquels le capital et le sort de
l'entreprise restent entre les mains des
salariés sont
exemplaires tant au niveau social que
qu'au niveau du dynamisme et économique
je sais d'ailleurs que monsieur le
ministre de la Cohésion enfin que
Monsieur le Ministre ici présent n'est
pas insensible à ce type de structure
car il sait qu'aujourd'hui les scops
résistent mieux à la crise que les
autres pourquoi ne pas s'en inspirer
étendre ce pouvoir C ce principe de
codécision à d'autres entreprises dans
lesquelles les salariés sont encore bien
trop souvent considérés comme de simples
factur de
production après ce bref détour cette
introduction sur ce qu devrait être un
véritable mécanisme de participation et
d'intéressement venons en à la
proposition de
loi l'objet de cette proposition de loi
est donc de permettre le déblocage
exceptionnel des primes de participation
et d'intéressement placés en éparne
salariale dans ce cadre les salariés
disposeront de 6 mois à compter de la
publication de la loi pour débloqué
jusqu'à 20000 € nets de prélèvements
sociaux les sommes ainsi débloquées y
compris les les intérêts bénéficieront
d'une exonération d'imposition sur le
revenu sous réserve de la CSG et de la
CRDS sur les intérêts je rappelle la
situation
actuelle soit le salarié choisit Lespes
salariale sur 5 ans voire 8 ans soit
demande le vercement de la somme définie
mais aujourd'hui il est soumis à
taxation cette somme est soumise à
taxation le déblocage ne sera toutefois
pas autorisé à juste titre pour les
sommes gérées par un PERCO plan d'épre
de retraite collectif ni pour cell
investies sur un fond
solidaire comme cela a été dit avant moi
la mure qui nous est présenté intervient
dans un contexte particulier celui de la
plus forte baisse de pouvoir d'achat des
Français depuis
1984 j'ajoute que plusieurs dispositifs
similaires ont été mis en place au cours
de ces 20 dernières années anné au moins
qu en un peu moins de 20 ans et que
s'agissant du dernier dat celui de 2008
qui devait en principe permettre
d'injecter 12 milliards d'euros dans
l'économie il a permis le déblocage de
seulement 3,9 milliards d'euros nous
rappelons également comme l'avait fait
judicieusement remarqué madame la
rapporteur lors de nos débats en
commission que ce type de dispositif
peut avoir un effet d'auè et détourner
lespne salariale vers d'autres placement
plus rémunérateur type livrea ou
assurance vie il en a été ainsi lors du
déblocage de 2004 où 70 % des sommes
liées à l'intéressement ou à la
participation ont été replacés sur des
supports d'épanne plus liquides ou plus
rémunérateur et nous espérons que le
fléchage vers les achats de biens et de
services prévus dans la proposition de
loi permettra de lutter efficacement
contre les dérives du système donc donc
en
conclusion malgré les quelques réserves
que nous venons de formuler le groupe
écologiste ne s'opposera pas à une
mesure visant à permettre dans un
contexte difficile aux 9 millions de
salariés qui en bénéficie de puiser dans
leur éparne pour améliorer le pouvoir
d'achat le groupe écologiste apportera
donc son soutien à la proposition de loi
sur le déblocage exceptionnel de la
participation et de
l'intéressement tout en attendant
beaucoup du projet de loi sur la consomm
en particulier sur les mesures qu'il
entend prendre à distinition des
chômeurs des précaires des salariés plus
modestes qui ne bénéficient pas de prime
de participation ni de prime
d'intéressement enfin en ce qui concerne
cette proposition de loi les élus
écologistes se prononcent pour son
adoption remci merci chers collègu la
parole est à Madame Jacqueline alier
pour le groupe
socialiste
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre madame la rapporteur chers
collègues nous le savons tous le pouvoir
d'achat des Français est aujourd'hui en
berne certains collègues l'ont rappelé
un recul de 0,4 % a été observé en 2012
chose qui ntait plus arrivé depuis
1984 au même titre que l'emploi le
pouvoir d'achat est l'une des grandes
causes nationales sur le plan économique
depuis un an le gouvernement et la
majorité parlementaire se mobilise pour
adopter les mesures nécessaires et
encourager les entreprises de ce pays
plutôt que d'expliquer que ces mesures
seraient insuffisante qu'elle ne serait
qu'elle ne ferait qu'illustrer le
soi-disant immobilisme du gouvernement
laissantleur le temps de produire leurs
effets les auteurs de ces critiques
savent à penser qu'ils ne rentrent
jamais dans leurs circonscription savent
pertin
que des mesures ne sont jamais desffits
immédiats que ce soit en terme d'emploi
de santé ou
d'éducation sur le sujet qui nous
intéresse aujourd'hui notre réaction qui
consiste à débloquer une partie de
l'épargne salariale afin de l'orienter
vers la consommation principal moteur de
la croissance de notre modèle économique
actuel va permettre en effet de donner
un coup de pouce au pouvoir d'achat des
Français à cet écart je voudrais
d'ailleurs appeler à l'opposition
qu'elle ne peut sans cesse imputer à la
gauche après seulement un an d'action
les problèmes de pouvoir d'achat des
Français d'ailleurs lorsqu'elle était au
aux responsabilités le déblocage de
l'épargne salariale adopté n'était
assorti d'aucune condition et n'a donc
eu aucun effet véritable sur la
consommation ou moindre il vaut mieux
donc s'abstenir de donner toute
prévision je voudrais à ce titre
souligner la présence d'esprit de nos
collègues députés qui ont demandé au
gouvernement le dépôt d'un rapport
réalisant le bilan de la mesure dans le
délai d'un an après son
adoption ce rapport nous permettra sans
doute et pour la première fois depuis 20
ans de disposer dans les mois qui
viennent de données fiables sur l'effet
d'un tel déblocage à travers les
précédentes intervention de nos
collègues de la majorité nous avons pu à
nouveau revenir sur les objectifs de ce
texte qui aura des effets positifs tant
sur le plan micro-économique que
macro-économique il est en effet
salutaire de permettre au français de
débloquer leur épargne salariale en
temps de crise sans pénalité fiscale par
ce texte nous comblons temporairement un
manque de la loi celle-ci prévoit déjà
un déblocage anticipé en cas de coup dur
mais ne prévoit rien en temps de crise
économique il fallait donc permettre ce
déblocage afin d'orienter une partie de
l'épargne salariale aujourd'hui
indisponible vers la
consommation le dispositif proposé est
de de nature a redonné quelques Marg de
manœuvre au ménage pour faire face à des
achats de BI durables ou d'équipement
une autre amélioration doit être relevée
dans ce texte le déblocage exceptionnel
porte aussi sur l'intéressement ce qui
n'est pas négligeable cela va permettre
de ne pas s'adresser uniquement aux
salariés des grandes entreprises mais
aussi à ceux qui travaillent au sein des
petites entreprises et qui ont le plus
souvent accès à
l'intéressement notre action est simple
lisible et espérons-le efficace mais il
est important de rappeler que nous ne
concevons pas aujourd'hui ou demain
l'épargne salariale l'intéressement ou
la participation à des substituts du
salaire ce qui nous préoccupe en premier
lieu dans notre action politique c'est
la hausse des salaires les plus bas et
la juste répartition des richesses au
sein de l'entreprise prenons garde à ne
pas perdre de vue que l'outil de
rémunération du travail c'est le salaire
en cela notre proposition de l'or même
si elle est actuellement nécessaire doit
nous questionner aussi sur les
déséquilibres dans le partage des
richesses au sein de l'entreprise il ne
s'agit donc pas de parvenir à une juste
répartition entre ce qui doit relever de
la rémunération du travail qui se fait
sous forme de salaire et ce qui
correspond à la participation au
l'intéressement je tiens d'ailleurs à
souligner la pertinence de la décision
du gouvernement lorsqu'il se prononce
contre la mise en place d'un système de
prime défiscalisé et désocialisé au sein
des entreprises où n'existe pas de tel
dispositif car lorsque les entreprises
ont les moyens de procéder à des
augmentations de salire elles doivent le
faire c'est à l'avantage du salarié des
régimes sociaux qui sont du même coup
abondés par ses
augmentation contrairement aux
précédentes mesures de déblocage je
voudrais aussi souligner la vigilance
des auteurs du texte les exceptions au
déblocage que constituent les PERCO qui
permettent de compléter une retraite et
ce ce qui relève de l'épargne solidaire
son judicieuses l'épargne réalisée sur
le long terme ne doit pas être remise en
cause pas plus que celle qui permet des
financements pérennes en direction des
entreprises de l'économie sociale et
solidaire monsieur le ministre yveille
dont on connaît de les besoins en fond
propres ce n'est pas le moment de
déstabiliser un secteur qui fonctionne
bien qui a du sens et qui crée depuis 10
ans 23 % d'emplois nouveaux quand le
secteur privé traditionnel n'en créé que
7 %. ce secteur doit d'ailleurs devenir
un plan essentiel de notre politique de
croissance par ailleurs nos collègues
députés ont introduit un certain nombre
d'amendements permettant de clarifier le
dispositif il fallait bien sû préciser
les dates d'application du dispositif ce
qui a été fait nous devions aussi
garantir le fléchage des sommes
débloquées au profit de la consommation
afin de ne pas voir cet argent au profit
de la consommation afin de ne pas voir
cet argent par vers des produits
d'épargne plus rémunérateur pour mémoire
70 % des sommes débloqué en 2004 ont été
immédiatement épargné sans même profiter
à la consommation il était donc
nécessaire de cibler un minimum les
conditions du débloquage mais veillons à
ne pas introduire trop de conditions au
risque de rendre ce dispositif
incompréhensible pour les salariés
certes il est indispensable de limiter
les effets d'auè l'Assemblée nationale a
pour cela prévu de procédure de contrôle
allégé imposant au salariés
bénéficiaaires de la mesure de tenir à
la disposition de l'administration les
pièces justificative attestant l'usage
des sommes
débloquées ce mécanisme a deux rémérites
il évite de décourager les salariés
désireux de bénéficier du déblocage par
un formalisme excessif tout en posant
suffisamment de conditions pour
décourager les abus mais attention nous
n'avons pas demandé de contrepartie aux
entreprises lors de la mise en place du
Crédit Impôt comp itivité emploi et nous
avons veillé à mettre en place un
mécanisme simple il doit donc en être de
même lorsque l'on s'adresse au salariés
qui dans le cas contraire ne
comprendraiit pas le sens de notre
action ce dispositif limité dans le
temps et correctement ciblé aura toute
son efficacité ne portera pas atteinte à
l'outil même de l'intéressement et de la
participation il faut d'ailleurs le
faire
évoluerélargir afin de réduire les
inégalités entre salariés car lorsque
l'on observe l'évolu de la participation
de l'intéressement et de l'éparne
salariale on s'aperçoit que la
répartition des primes est beaucoup trop
plus inégalitaire les montants versés
entre les salariés d'une même entreprise
ne sont pas identiques aussi le nombre
de bénéficiaires est encore trop faible
dans les entreprises de moins de 50
salariés très nombreuses dans notre pays
pour qu'elle puisse s'approprier cet
outil il faudra encore le simplifi les
10 lois qui ont été adoptées depuis 2001
n'ont fait que complexifier le
dispositif et don éloigner d'un certain
nombre de nos entreprises les réflexions
qui vont s'engager prochainement
pourront peut-être se pencher sur la
manière de développer les incitations
pour les jeunes salariés les plus
modestes C ces deux catégories ayant un
très faible taux d'épargne comme nous
l'avons fait avec les emplois d'avenir
et les contrats de génération nous
devons maintenir notre attention sur les
salariés les moins protégés sans opposer
les et les autres cessons de créer
systématiquement de nouveaux droits pour
ceux qui sont déjà les mieux protégés
poursuivons notre combat en faveur des
plus fragiles le constat d'une société
où les inégalités de toute nature se
creusent doit nous pousser à agir en ce
sens celui d'une politique de soutien en
faveur des plus défavorisés enfin il
sera sans doute nécessaire de réfléchir
à une possible révision de la formule de
calcul de la participation et ce afin
d'encourager les entreprises à partager
plus équitablement les fruit de leur
production mais il convient pour le
moment d'attendre que les négociations
soi lancées par le ministre ministre du
Travail Michel Sapin sont annoncés et de
voir par la suite sur quel type de
proposition déboucheront pour le moment
le test qui nous est soumis est une
mesure d'urgence bien calibrée cette
mesure est un nouveau levier qu'il ne
faut pas négliger elle s'inscrit dans la
stratégie globale de notre gouvernement
en faveur de la consommation et du
pouvoir d'achat et intervient à un
moment crucial pour notre économie pour
toutes ces raisons notre groupe le
groupe de la majorité se prononcera bien
évidemment en faveur de ce texte merci
chers
collègues la parole est à Monsieur le
Ministre merci monsieur le Président je
je voulais quand même faire quelques
réponses et quelques commentaires au
terme de la discussion générale et avant
d'aborder
euh les les amendements
euh je voudrais dire euh au au groupe
CRC euh au sénateur Vatin que
euh je comprends j'accepte parfaitement
que sur les bands de la gauche on puisse
exprimer des désaccords des nuances avec
des choix de politique économique qui
sont ceux du gouvernement qu'on peut
exprimer des regrets vis-à-vis de la
question des licenciements boursiers
comme vous l'avez fait des regrets par
rapport aux questions salariales tout ça
dans un contexte de crise mais je
voudrais que vous reteniez
ceci l'affirmation qui est celle de ce
gouvernement est de dire et de répéter
que N nous ne confondons pas la question
de la participation et la question du
salaire et comme ça a été très bien dit
par le sénateur Desessard nous
considérons que la participation
l'intéressement sont des instruments qui
permettent une répartition des profits
et un intéressement des salariés au
résultat de l'entreprise là où le
salaire rémunère le travail et il a été
dit d'ailleurs sur les bans je crois du
groupe je crois que c'était monsieur
Marseille qui qui l'a dit tout à l'heure
madame Debray que le choix que nous
avons fait d'augmenter le forfait social
à l'exception des scopes au passage sur
la participation et l'intéressement
était une manière de dire que nous ne
voulions pas que l'épargne salariale se
substitue au salaire ces engagement nous
les prenons mais je dis je vous dis au
groupe communiste
que l'abstention sur ce texte je
comprends ça été à l'Assemblée nationale
c'est aussi prendre le risque ou la
responsabilité que pour des millions de
salariés cette épargne salariale dont
ils ont besoin
aujourd'hui ne puisse pas être débloqué
débloqué pour des dépenses qu'il juge
indispensables et des dépenses qui iront
alimenter l'activité donc l'emploi donc
les salaires d'autres travailleurs en
France et je pense que je peux
comprendre vos désaccords nous avons des
discussions ces débats existent à gauche
comme il y en a avec le groupe Union
centriste mais mais je veux redire que
l'existence de ces désaccords moi
m'amène à à forcément ne pas comprendre
forcément le raisonnement qui vous amène
à à vous abstenir et à ne pas voter en
faveur d'une mesure qui reste favorable
à un nombre trop peu important des
salariés je préférerais moi aussi que
tous sont bénéficie mais une mesure qui
sera une mesure utile à ses salariés
mais utile indirectement à d'autres à
travers l'utilisation qu'ils feront de
ces fonds au groupe Union centriste je
dirais une autre
chose on peut ne pas être d'accord avec
les mesures que nous avons pris sur le
cice on peut vouloir davantage de
réduction de la dépense publique
on peut vouloir une politique qui soit
une politique de réduction des impôts on
peut vouloir tout cela et en même temps
nous savons vous et moi qu'il va falloir
arracher chaque demi-point de croissance
chaque diè de croissance or cette mesure
là elle va consacrer près de 3 milliards
d'euros dans l'économie
ou à l'achat de biens ou à l'achat de
service j'ai parfaitement compris la
philosophie qui est la vôre sur la
mesure que vous proposez de réduction du
du du champ d'application mais je redis
là encore pourquoi s'interdire la
possibilité qu'à travers cette épargne
salariale on achète une voiture un bien
et au passage pour acheter une voiture
hélas on a besoin d'un peu plus de 10000
€ Madame Debray ça peut être une Picasso
20000 € une mégane 18000 € une 308
pourquoi s'indire d'acheter des biens
fabriqués ici là où cette mesure là
encore aura un impact en terme de
consommation et d'emploi et c'est là que
je je autant je comprends la philosophie
autant je je ne partage pas forcément la
logique qui consiste à dire au terme de
votre raisonnement que vous voteriez
contre cette mesure dont vous semblez
partager la nécessité en terme d'impact
sur la consommation puis la dernière
chose je la dirai à Madame
Debray d'ord je vous féliciter
c'est la première fois depuis 1 an je
suis pas sûr que vous appréciez
totalement le compliment mais quand
même mais je préfère vous dire vous
préparer quand même c'est la première
fois depuis un an que je vois une
parlementaire se faire applaudir derriur
par les sénateurs dump en faisant un
inventaire d'une mesure prise par
Nicolas Sarkozi qui soit négatif pas de
chance ça tombe sur moi mais au moment
où j'espérais mais mais mais je veux
dire c'est je veux dire que c'est
remarquable parce que c'est honnête
c'est pas de chance parce que je dis que
ça va vous amener à voter contre la
mesure que l'on propose cela étant dit
le reproche que je pourrais vous faire
c'est que cet inventaire ne vous amène
pas jusqu'à considérer que si le pouvoir
d'achat a baissé en 2012 et vous avez
raison c'est bien en raison de la
modération salarielle et du fait que les
gens ont moins de revenus dans la poche
et en raison des augmentations d'impôts
qui en 2012 pour ce qui s'applique en
2012 sur les 20 milliards d'euros qui
concernent les augmentations d'euros 13
milliards sont dans des lois de finances
avant mai 2012 et 7 milliards pour nous
donc si le pouvoir d'achat a baissé pour
les Français c'est au moins pour moitié
voir même plus de la moitié en raison
des augmentations d'impôts que vous avez
voté donc bon ce que je veux simplement
vous dire c'est que je je reconnais cela
en même temps je je veux vous inviter
c'est pour ça que je voulais intervenant
la discussion générale à apprécier ce
texte pour ceux qui
on va essayer d'arracher le demi-point
les diièm de croissance dont on a besoin
et je pense que cette mesure est une
mesure utile parce que ça fait de la
consommation parce que la consommation
crée de l'activité j'entends les
arguments sur les politiques de l'offre
on a besoin des deux tout le monde le
sait et au passage l'investissement
n'est pas une composante de l'offre
c'est une composante de la demande
aujourd'hui donc nous avons besoin des
deux et des deux ça passe par une mesure
qui est une mesure aussi
importante que celle-là même si si je le
dis au nom du gouvernement nous savons
qu'elle ne résout pas tout et nous
n'avons jamais prétendu à cela je vous
remercie merci Monsieur le
Ministre la discussion générale est
close la commission n'ayant pas adopté
de texte nous passons à la discussion
des articles de la proposition de loi
transmise par l'Assemblée nationale sur
l'article 1er j'ai une demande de parole
Monsieur Dominique
Vrin oui une petite explication sur le
le sceptic que j'ai exprimé dans mon
intervention générale et qui se double
aussi ça explique aussi peut-être en
réponse aux interrogations du ministre
notre abstention c'est une inquiétude
aussi sur la stratégie de croissance qui
est affichée par le gouvernement et là
nous avons
effectivement une forte inquiétude aussi
vous avez notamment rallé monsieur le
ministre récemment la décision de la
Commission européenne préconisant
préconisant un rythme de consolidation
budgétaire je cite la phrase plus
compatible avec les exigen de croissance
dans la zone euro dire que nous ne
partageons pas votre analyse et je
regrette d'ailleurs que vous
satisfassiez de cette annonce ceci
d'autant que le candidat François
Hollande avait promis de renégocier le
traité européen mais qu'il s'est au
final contenté d'un simple affichage de
crédit qui était en réalité déjà
programmé de plus qu'on peut constater
c'est que en échange de cette enveloppe
financière les États doivent s'engager
des réformes structurelles notamment C
du marché du travail qui ne sont pas
sans rappeler la stratégie de Lisbonne
que vous condamniez alors Monsieur le
Ministre d'ailleurs je rappellerai une
citation d'un ancien gouverneur de la
Banque centrale qui expliquait le but de
cette stratégie je cite atténuer le
diaphragme des protections qui au cours
du 20e siècle ont progressivement
éloigné l'individu du contact direct
avec la dureté de la vie avec les
renforce verersements de fortune avec la
sanction ou la la récompense de ces
défauts et qualités tout un programme
bien éloigné vous en conviendrez des
fondements du programme du Conseil
National de la Résistance que nous
célébrions hier c'est au nom de ces
dogmes européens je pense que votre
gouvernement a voulu la transposition de
laanque il a fait le choix de taxer les
retraités qui s'apprêteent demain à
réformer les retraites en allongeant la
durée de cotisation c'est toujours dans
cette logique qu'à l'Assemblée nationale
et encore aujourd'hui au Sénat vous avez
affirmé monsieur le ministre que le
second taxe de votre politique reposait
sur la restauration des marges de
l'entreprise restauration chacun
comprendra qu'elle se fera sur le dos
des salaires et des salariés que
notamment des réductions de cotisation
patronnal qui constituent depuis 45 un
salaire socialisé permettant de financer
notre système de santé notre politique
familiale ou encore notre système de
retraite au final ce sont donc bien les
salariés qui une fois encore seront les
grands perdants d'une politique
d'austérité enfin monsieur le ministre
permettez-moi de vous interroger sur les
conséquences de cet article premier j'y
arrive sur les sociétés coopératives et
d'une manière plus globale sur
l'économie sociale et solidaire à
laquelle vous êtes je le sais
particulièrement attaché comme vous le
savez les scopes obé obéissent à des
principes particuliers de gouvernance
puisque les salariés sont étroitement
associés participent à la direction de
l'entreprise leur financement est
également singulier en effet la
participation est majoritairement
réinvestie en interne et constitue un
moyen essentiel de financement des
actifs et des activités qui permet aux
entreprises de se développer sans avoir
recours au crédit ce mode de financement
explique sans doute pourquoi les scopes
sont généralement très compétitives et
savent répondre aux enjeux liés à la
concurrence y compris international et à
la modernisation des outils de
production alors cette mesure comme en
2004 et en 2008 inquiète un certain
nombre d'acteurs de l'économie sociale
et solidaire ceuxci craignent que le
déblocage anticipé des des fonds de la
participation ne déséquilibre les bilans
qui plusit cette mesure pourêtre être
pourrait être un mauvais coup à
l'économie sociale et solidaire puisque
chaque plan d'épargne d'entreprise est
légalement contraint d'investir entre 5
et 10 % de ses encours dans un fond de
l'économie solidaire les encours étant
de fait réduits l'investissement dans ce
secteur sera nécessairement réduit
semble-t-il pour des effets sur la
consommation des plus incertains
pourtant le secteur de l'économie
sociale et solidaire pourrait être
lui-même source de création d'emploi et
de richesse aussi monsieur le ministre
monsieur le ministre pardon
pourriez-vous nous apporter quelques
précisions en tout cas plus de précision
à
ce merci chers collègu nous en arrivons
à l'amendement 4 rectifié il est
présenté par Madame
debr merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
cet amendement concerne le champ
d'application de la mesure de dé blocage
comme je le disais dans mes propos
liminires pour éviter que les
entreprises ne voient leur capacité
d'investissement se contracter faute de
pouvoir disposer de financement nous
proposons que le déblocage des avoirs
détenus par les salariés ne soit
possible que pour les avoirs placés dans
les fonds monétaires et non dans ceux
investis en action les fonds investis
principalement en action représentent 50
milliards d'euros sur un en cours total
de
94,6 milliards d'euros il semble
essentiel de sanctuire les fonds actions
qui concourent de manière significative
au financement de l'économie par le
biais des fonds propres des entreprises
tel est l'objet de cet amendement je
vous remercie merci chers collègues
madame le rapporteur quel est l'avis de
la
commission cet amendement propose de
réduire considérablement le champ de la
mesure prévue par le texte de la
proposition de loi en limitant le
déblocage aux sommes intégralement
investies en actifs monétaires ou
obligataire compte tenu de cette de sa
rédaction cet amendement exclut non
seulement les fonds communs de placement
et les SICAV d'actionnariat salariés
mais également la majeure partie des
fonds diversifiés puisque 63 % de des en
courours euh sont euh se compose d'une
part plus ou moins importante d'action
en fonction de leur sensibilité au
risquequ donc au total l'amendement
divise par 4 l'en cours d'Épagne
salariale déblocable réduisant de ce
fait drastiquement l'effet attendu de la
mesure sur la consommation et le pouvoir
d'achat je tiens par ailleurs à ajouter
qu'en aboutissant à autoriser un
déblocage sans conditions des fonds que
l'entreprise consacre à des
investissements le texte de la
proposition de loi prévoit quant à lui
la nécessité de signature d'un accord
collectif pour débloquer ses fonds cet
amendement pourrait perturber
considérablement les projets de
l'entreprise concernée et je tiens enfin
à vous rassurer sur l'impact potentiel
de la mesure sur le financement des
entreprises françaises la capitalisation
des entreprises du CAC 40 représente
près de 1000 milliards d'euros tandis
que les fonds diversifiés investis
toutou parti en action représente 32
milliards d'euros considérant que 10 %
de ces sommes investies en fonds
diversifiés devrai être effectivement
débloqué et que ces fonds se composent
d'un bouquet d'action internationale et
non pas seulement française l'effet de
la mesure sur le financement des
entreprises nationales devrait être
infinitésimale et pour toutes ces
raisons la commission a donné un avis
défavorable à cet amendement merci
Madame la rapporteur monsieur le
ministre l'avis du Gouvernement oui ben
même avis euh que Madame la rapporteur
pour le principal argument c'est le
champ qui serait considérablement
restreint le champ de la mesure donc
nous voulons optimiser l'impact de ce
dispositif donc avis
défavorable merci alors nous allons
voter sur cet amendement pas de demande
d'explication de vote que ceux qui
souhaitent l'adopté veuille bien lever
la
main merci que ceux qui sont contre
veille bien lever la main
l'amendement n'est pas
adopté nous en arrivons à l'amendement
numéro 3 il est présenté par Madame
Debray merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
cet amendement vise à préciser les
démarches incombant au salariés avant le
déblocage des avoirs par le teneur de
compte il tente également à faire du
teneur de compte l'interlocuteur unique
de l'administration fiscale en cas de
contrôle portant sur l'usage des sommes
débloquées nous proposons en premier
lieu que le teneur de compte débloque
les avoirs détenus par le salarié sur
simple présentation d'une déclaration
sur l'honneur mentionnant l'utilisation
des sommes qui lui seront versées par
ailleurs nous proposons que le teneur de
compte soit le détenteur des factures
correspondant aux achats effectués par
le salarié en cas de contrôle je
rappelle que bien évidemment ces teneurs
de comptees sont soumis au secret
professionnel comme bien sûr toutes les
banques en effet l'objectif recherché
Vous en avez parlé monsieur le ministre
est que cette somme débloquées soit
utilisé pour pour des achats
relativement importants voire comme vous
le soullignez tout à l'heure des projets
d'ensemble vous parliez d'une cuisine
donc un certificat sur l'honneur sur un
projet d'ensemble euh des travaux
l'immobilier des travaux l'automobile le
gros électroménager plutôt qu'une
multitude de petits produits souvent
importés qui ne résoudront rien en rien
le problème de l'emploi dans notre pays
et pourrait accentuer notre déficit
commercial et je signale aussi que ça
serait un moyen beaucoup plus facile
pour l'éventuel contrôle comme l'a
souligné l'ont souligné plusieurs de nos
collègues garder une multitude de
petites factures je dirais même de
facturettes pour le salarié ça me paraît
tout simplement ingérable aussi bien
pour le salarié de tout conserver que
pour le contrôleur de tout contrôler et
c'est pour ça que nous avons déposer cet
amendement qui résout ce problème je
vous remercie merci chers collègues
madame le rapporteur quel est l'avis de
la
commission alors la la commission a
constaté que c que cet amendement
complexifie considérablement le
dispositif de contrôle applicable à la
mesure de déblocage introduit par nos
collègues députés sans pour autant
accroître son efficacité en amont de la
procédure il propose d'une part de
conditionner le déblocage des fonds à
une déclaration sur l'honneur auprès du
teneur de compte précisant l'usage des
sommes débloquées et une fois le
déblocage effectué il impose au teneurs
de compte de tenir à la disposition de
l'administration fiscale non seulement
la déclaration sur l'honneur mais aussi
l'ensemble des pièces justificatives
attestant de l'usage des sommes
débloquées y compris les facturettes
comme le les appelé madame madame Debray
donc ce dispositif pose un certain
nombre de questions d'abord quelle est
la valeur juridique d'une déclaration
sur
l'honneur à quel moment et dans quelles
conditions le salarier devra-t-il
transmettre les pièces justificatives
attestant de l'usage des sommes
débloquées au teneur de
compte et les contraintes
supplémentaires imposé au teneurs de
compte gestion archivage classement des
millions de justificatifs potentiels
sont justifieré compte tenu de cette
interrogation et de la la lourdeur
qu'entraînerait en l'état la mise en
place d'un tel mécanisme de contrôle la
commission a émis un avis défavorable à
cet amendement merci madame le
rapporteur monsieur le ministre quel est
l'avis du Gouvernement
oui écoutez même avis que Madame la
rapporteur la réalité c'est quoi c'est
qu'on a eu des dispositifs de déblocage
l'épaggne salarial qui ont fonctionné
d'autres un peu moins dès qu'on rajoute
excessivement de formalisme on sait très
bien que l'on atteint l'objectif du
dispositif qui est de permettre de
débloquer de l'argent le Parlement en
tout cas l'Assemblée nationale a
souhaité mettre en place un un système
de contrôle sous la forme de
l'obligation pour le salarié de
conserver les justificatifs qui peuvent
être exigibles dans n'importe quel
contrôle de l'administration fiscale
simple nous considérons que c'est
suffisant sauf là encore à à
complexifier à alourdir un dispositif
dont nous souhaitons qu'il reste le plus
simple possible et et Perm un déblocage
de l'épargne salariale merci monsieur le
ministre c'est un avis
défavorable merci bien nous allons voter
sur l'amendement numéro 3 je n'ai pas de
demande d'explication de vote que ceux
qui souhaitent l'adopter veille bien
lever la
main merci que ceux qui sont contre
veille bien lever la main l'amendement
n'est pas adopté nous en arrivons à
l'amendement numéro 7 il est présenté
par Monsieur von
lurenberg
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues l'objet de
cet amendement monsieur le ministre vous
avez vous l'avez évoqué dans votre
propos initial et de concentrer le
dispositif du déblocage exceptionnel sur
la fourniture de service et non l'achat
de bien manufacturés autrement dit c'est
l'investissement qu'il faut favoriser et
non espérer relancer la croissance par
la consommation au lieu de relancer
l'investissement le déblocage de la
participation et l'intéresse pourrait
contribuer au contraire à le fragiliser
davantage en privant les entreprises de
fonds propres dans ces conditions il
faut à minima s'assurer que les fonds
débloqués servent pleinement à alimenter
l'économie nationale autrement dit il
faut veiller à ce qu'il ne soit pas
détournés de leur objet c'est d'ailleurs
pour éviter cet écueil que nos collègues
députés ont d'une pas ont limité l'usage
des sommes débloquées c'est une première
assurance incontestablement
mais nous pensons qu'il faut aller plus
loin pour que chaque euro débloqué
soutienne pleinement l'économie
nationale en ciblant la mesure sur la
fourniture de services donc en excluant
l'achat de bien manufacturé du
dispositif en effet par définition les
services ne sont pas délocalisables et
ce serait un premier signal tangible en
direction des secteurs aussi cruciux
cruciaux pardon que ceux du bâtiment ou
des services à la personne qui sont sont
d'ailleurs monsieur le ministre souvent
gérés par des des associations donc par
l'économie sociale et solidaire ces deux
secteurs ont jusqu'ici été très durement
affectés par la politique menée par
votre majorité alors qu'il recessell un
potentiel de croissance et d'emploi
considérable il mérite donc d'être
maintenant substantiellement soutenu au
contraire l'achat de bien manufacturé
contribuerait à la dégradation de la
balance commerciale si on ne le contrôle
pas nombre des 10 produits étant
évidemment importé alors vous nous
avancez qu'il s'agit de soutenir la
grande distribution qui crée des emplois
en France nous l'entendons mais la
grande distribution à ma connaissance
n'est pas en crise alors que la France
l'Est il est aussi allégué que la mesure
entend soutenir l'automobile bah
j'entends bien mais soyons franc cette
mesure est bien trop modeste pour avoir
un impact sur la croissance durable de
ce secteur mais monsieur le ministre si
vous voulez faire voter néanmoins votre
loi peut-être serions-nous prêts à faire
une exception pour l'automobile et
examiner une modification qui limiterait
l'achat de bien à
l'automobile tous les cas monsieur le
ministre sachez que cet amendement pour
nous important parce que il reflète une
certaine logique du développement de
l'économie préservant effectivement
l'emploi et l'emploi durable en
France ch collègue madame la rapporteur
quel est
Monsieur en explication de vote monsieur
le Président alors d'abord l'avis
d'abord l'avis voilà de madame le
rapporteur alors la Commission a
considéré effectivement que l'objectif
de de cet amendement était louable
puisque une partie des sommes débloqué
effectivement financer l'acquisition de
de biens d'importation pour autant cet
amendement nous paraît trop restrictif
et et ce pour plusieurs raisons il
réduirait d'abord à néant l'objectif
essentiel de la mesure qui consiste à
relancer la consommation des ménages
notamment où celle-ci connaît un point
bas historique il décevrait ensuite les
attentes de la plupart de nos
compatriotes qui souhaitent utiliser
cette épargne pour s'équiper comme ils
l'entendent et et surtout il ferait
sortir du champ de la mesure dépend
entier de notre industrie et de notre
économie à commencer par l'automobile
que vous avez cité le commerce de
proximité susceptible de bénéficier des
sommes libérées à l'occasion du
déblocage et je note qu'historiquement
aucune des mesures de déblocage
précédentes dont on a pourtant évoqué
l'efficacité ne s'est vu imposer une
telle restriction et donc la commission
a émis un avis défavorable sur cet
amendement merci Madame rapporteur
monsieur le ministre quel est viis du
gouvernement moi je crois que je l'ai
abondamment dit il est défavorable mais
je veux je veux reprendre mon mon
exemple
euh je veux profiter de mon épargne
salariale je veux me faire une
veréranda je pourrais donc avoir sur ma
facture
main-dœuvre 2000 € euh et euh équipement
euh matériel tant de milliers d'euros je
pourrais donc utiliser ce que j'ai
débloqué pour payer la main d'œuvre
service mais pas
l'équipement mais si parce que vous
achetez un bien la je reprends un autre
exemple votre cuisine mais non parce que
sur votre facture non ce n'est pas vrai
c'est monsieur le sénateur je vous le
redis vous c'est pas c'est effectivement
une prestation globale pour la main
d'œuvre mais vous achèteriez le service
mais vous n'auriez pas pour la cuisine
la possibilité d'utiliser cette épargne
salariale pour acheter le meuble le
frigidaire et la cuisinière donc je
pense que ça ne fonctionnerait pas je je
je vous le dis c'est juste pour ça je
pense ça fonctionnerait pas mais je veux
redire un autre argument les emplois
vous parlez de la grande distribution
mais ça n'est pas que cela il y
a des dizaines de milliers d'emplois
dans l'économie nationale qui sont liés
à la vente et à la commercialisation de
produits importés et et le fait
aujourd'hui de soutenir l'achat d'un
bien c'est aussi soutenir ces emplois là
il ne nous revient pas nous aujourd'hui
de hiérarchis
un emploi dans la grande distribution
dans le commerce pardon de vous dire
dans le petit commerce aussi qui vend
des biens d'équipement et un emploi dans
l'industrie française au regard du fait
que tel ou tel produit est importé
donc ça m difficile donc de vous
donner raison y compris sur le
sous-amendement que vous pourriez
proposer qui est pour les véhicule
français parce que nous considérons que
si nous voulons que la mesure est de
l'impact elle doit concerner les biens
d'équipement et les services sauf à
rater sa cible et sa cible je le redis
c'est la consommation des ménages et
derrière la consommation des ménages
c'est l'emploi monurforable alors pour
explication de vote la parole est à
Monsieur
repsamen Merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre chers collègues
jeis vous dire moi je comprends tout à
fait l'esprit de de l'amendement que
vous avez déposé en en précisant et
d'ailleurs c'est cela qui nous en donne
l'esprit non délocalisable on voit bien
la recherche que que vous avez que
l'impact de de cette mesure qui n'est
pas forcément qui sera pas forcément
d'ailleurs
insignifiante sur l'économie française
quand on cherche effectivement cela a
été dit
aujourd'hui des des demi-points des des
bouts de croissance
tout ce qui concourt à la consommation
en la matière à relancer l'activité
économique au sens large et est
favorable donc moi moi il y a de deux ou
trois choses que je comprends pas quand
quand ces mesures ont été adoptées des
mesures identique par certains côtés
précédemment on a vous n'avez pas essayé
d'en limiter la portée est-ce que ça
voudrait dire que les mesures que vous
aviez prises à l'époque étaient de
mauvaises mesures vous pouvez le dire
aujourd'hui mais les dernières datent de
2008 autant que je me rappelle et donc
même si les premières commençaient en 94
donc on voit bien que quand il y a une
panne de de croissance liée à la
consommation que la situation est
difficile il est normal de permettre à
la consommation de
repartir les la démonstration du
ministre elle est quand même assez juste
chers collègues c'est c'est c'est pas
possible de considérer que on puisse
avoir tout à la fois les moyens sinon ça
se ferait sans sans ce déblocage tout à
la fois les moyens d'acheter j'allais
dire le matériel nécessaire si on
reprend l'exemple de de la veréranda et
de se faire grâce à cela on trouve
l'argent pour faire faire les les
travaux donc moi je je comprends mais
est-ce est-ce qu'il est pas possible
est-ce qu'il est pas possible de de
réfléchir encore parce que moi je pense
que c'est une mesure qui devrait nous
rassembler une mesure qui devrait nous
rassembler ce qui est pas possible de
réfléchir encore à un sous-amendement
qui prendrait en compte le fait que
effectivement notamment les services
pourrai être concernés mais on ne peut
pas écarter les les biens de de de
consommation courante les biens
d'équipement alors après gcart mais vous
l'avz pas fait il y a pas de de procès
en la matière procès d'intention sur
uniquement l'achat de
de bien français évidemment puisque
c'est contraire au à la libre
concurrence mais mais rien n'empêche
d'acheter je me permets de le dire ici
des véhicules français d'ailleurs si on
peut en faire voilà et et certains
véhicules français qui sont produits en
France produit en France et c'est une
mesure qui est qui est attendue et elle
est attendue y compris par les
constructeurs automobile français qui
produisent en France et donc en ayant
euh moi chez ess j'essaie de de trouver
un point de d'accommodement en ayant
peut-être un sous-amendement qui dise et
notamment les services je ne sais pas ça
me vient comme ça ùou les services on
devrait arriver quand même à à un accord
c'est c'est en tous les cas c'est le
sens de mon intervention en ayant bien
compris bien sûr votre insistance sur
sur la chose mais en la matière tout
tout concourt à tout dans l'économie et
ce qu'a dit le le ministre amont tout à
l'heure est tout à fait juste juste il y
a pas de il y a pas de de de sous emploi
créé en la matière ou maintenu par
l'activité économique de commerce et
cetera donc je pense que c'est une
mesure qui peut concourir ça sera pas
effectivement la révolution mais tout
compte en ce moment mesure qui pourrait
y concourir voilà ce que je voulais vous
dire merci chers collègues monsieur
honorenberg merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
président du groupe
socialiste j'entends bien ce que vous
dites moi je suis et nous sommes notre
groupe tout à fait ouvert à la
discussion pour peu que effectivement
monsieur le ministre soit prêt aussi à à
revoir son texte mais jusqu'à présent on
a eu l'impression que il était
intangible que c'était l'alpha et
l'oméga que il fallait en passer par là
pour être d'accord sur sur une mesure
qui paraissait exemplaire on sait très
bien qu'il y a des dangers dans cette
mesure on vient de de vous les rappeler
mais nous sommes aussi conscient qui
qu'il faut maintenir l'emploi ou tout au
moins essayer de le
sauvegarder
donc c'est pour ça que jeouvrais sur
l'automobile sur quand vous vous dites
monsieur le ministre sur les services
quand vous faites appel à une entreprise
à un artisan il va venir avec sa véranda
il peut parfaitement le prendre euh en
terme de service c'est pas on n'est pas
obligé de l'acheter euh directement euh
c'est une prestation globale de la même
pour une cuisine c'était l'argument
aussi que vous avanciez tout à l'heure
c'est une prestation globale je peux
vous le dire
d'expérience donc euh le les produits
sont compris dans la prestation si si si
si je vous assure alors c'est le le le
tout est dans l'interprétation
effectivement que l'on va donner à la
notion de service ou à à la la notion de
Bien d'équipement quand vous dites que
vous voulez favoriser le commerce de
proximité alors soyons sérieux on va pas
débloquer 5000 € 8000 € de ces fonds ou
alors c'est il y a un tour de
passe-pe pour protéger effectivement une
autre épargne mais on va pas faire ça
pour acheter des des choux et des
carottes au marché du coin soyons
sérieux donc
monsieur monsieur le
président repsen moi je suis tout prêt à
à examiner avec mon groupe peut-être
avec d'autres un amendement qui irait un
peu dans le sens que nous avons défendu
merci merci chers collègues monsieur le
ministre monsieur le ministre vous
voulez une suspension une
suspension bien nous nous
suspendons la séance est reprise euh
madame le Rapp monsieur le ministre
oui je voudrais juste faire une
rectification pour de mon amendement
l'amendement du Gouvernement qui tien
compte des remarques de la présence de
la commission pour dire non pas
notamment dans le secteur le secteur
automobile mais en
particulier bien madame le rapporteur
l'avis la commission a donné un avis
favorable un avis
favorable
donc c'est le 9 rectifié c'est le 9
rectifié rectifié
oui bien alors nous
sommes nous sommes nous sommes donc sur
l'amendement 9
rectifié en insérant les mots donc en
particulier dans le secteur de
l'automobile
oui écoutez ça fait 8 ans que je suis
élu au Sénat je n'ai jamais vu ça je
n'ai Jama non non non non non non non
pas pour un amendement où on rajoute
notamment en particulier on n'est pas au
théâtre ici on travaille ça c'est la
première chose non je suis désolée je me
mets rarement madame
desmontess vous me connaissez depuis
longtemps je me mets rarement en colère
mais là vraiment je suis très en colère
je trouve que c'est pas admissible ça
n'est pas admissible d'aller à la
recherche de voix comme ça uniquement et
en plus enfin franchement
bon si Madame nous l'avons fait mais
vous monsieur le ministre a été le
premier à reconnaître la façon dont je
travaille la façon dont je reconnais les
torts que nous avons pu avoir et les
corps que nous aurons plus tard je pense
que c'est une force de savoir
reconnaître cet or mais là aujourd'hui
je suis désolé je suis pas au théâtre et
je suis là pour travailler donc bien
évidemment mon groupe s'opposera à cet
amendement et pourtant moi aussi
Monsieur le Ministre j'étais d'accord
avec vous et je vous l'ai dit
précédemment lors de mon de mon
amendement c'était bien de de cibler
l'automobile les biens immobiliers je
vous l'ai dit les bâtiments et cetera je
vous ai proposé un amendement vous
l'avez refusé je nai je n'ai pas rallé
je n'ai rien dit j'ai accepté votre vote
mais là cier l'automobile alors que le
bâtiment va très mal et que d'autres
secteurs vont très mal et vous mettez en
particulier l'automobile mais qu'est-ce
que ça veut dire quelle portée juridique
à ce terme aucune donc bien évidemment
nous voterons contre cet amendement et
nous demandons Monsieur le Président
inscru un sur cet amendement je merci
chers collègues la parole est à Monsieur
deessard pour explication de vote
oui monsieur le Président je voulais
d'abord dire que j'allais pas m'opposer
à C amendement pour pas m'opposer à la
dynamique de cet amendement qui
permettra je crois une l'adoption de
cette proposition de loi donc je m'y
oppose pas mais d'un autre côté je ne
peux pas y être favorable dans le sens
que ça mérite une réflexion sur le
secteur de l'automobile qui n'a pas
réussi à faire la mutation des
nécessaire et s'il y avait des biens à
recommander et il il y aurait avec
l'automobile même si elle est dans une
situation difficile bien d'autres
secteurs écologiquement responsables en
et qui mériteraiit qu'on s'y intéresse
également donc à partir du moment on
commence à se lancer dans une liste et
bien ce n'est pas obligatoirement
celle-ci que je cet article que j'aurais
pris en premier donc pour cela je
m'abstiens pour pas aller contre la
dynamique de ces amendement mais je n'en
partage pas l'affichage merci chers
collègue pour explication de vote
monsieur Vran
oui moi je je n'entends pas du tout
l'idée que ce serait à travers cet
amendement un signal fort qui serait
adressé puisque le l'UDI UC nous dit
sera lié à l'amendement du
Gouvernement c'est particulièrement
étonnant qu'elle signale fort lorsque
cet amendement précisément dit
exactement l'inverse de celui qui avait
été présenté par le groupe uduc je
comprends pas donc en tout cas il y a
pour moi il y a pas de signal fort cet
ajout ne ne sert strictement à rien on
l'a vu et le troisème argument je crois
que c'est qu'on sème surtout une
illusion sur le fond une illusion son
qui peut croire qu'en ajoutant notamment
l'automobile on va favoriser la
production nationale alors qu'on sait le
nombre d'entreprises d'équipementti
automobile qui sont aujourd'hui
délocalisés voire même des entreprises
des groupes automobiles français qui
produisent au Maroc ou en tqui qui
rapatrie les voitures pour les vendre je
crois que c'est l'Union européenne qu'il
faut changer si on veut favoriser
l'automobile puisque c'est elle qui
interdit notamment de verser des primes
pour favoriser ou protéger notre
industrie nationale en tout cas je ne
voterai pas et groupe votera contre un
amendement qui crée une
illusion merci chers collègu
je non les explications de vote ont déjà
été faites non non je suis désolé alors
j'ai été saisi d'une demande de scrutin
public par le
groupeendver sur l'amendement du
Gouvernement donc j'étis saisi d'une
demande de scrutin public sur le groupe
UMP sur l'amendement numéro 9
rectifié ah oui c'est bon monsieur
vanberg monsieur le Président nous ne
sommes pas expliqués mais moi je
voudrais tout simplement dire
qu'effectivement euh ça s'éloigne on va
pas le cacher serait ridicule d'un point
de vue simplement sémantique ça
s'éloigne de l'amendement que nous
avions déposé mais pourquoi l'avons-nous
déposé parce qu'on voulait mettre
l'accent sur la délocalisation qu'il
fallait éviter à tout prix et la
d'essayer de favoriser la consommation
nationale c'est ça le but que nous
recherchions
donc effectivement nous ciblons
l'automobile alors l'expression était
peut-être pas très
heureuse je crois queon aurait peut-être
plus travailler plus en amont
excusez-moi monsieur le ministre
euh nous aurions pu peut-être travailler
mais oui mais écoutez c'est une
expression française donc on aurait pu
travailler plutôt pour essayer de
trouver une rédaction qui nous convienne
elle est imparfaite mais je crois que
l'esprit que nous souhaitons c'était
effectivement euh c'est un coup hein
c'est one shot comme j'ai dit essayer de
donner un coup de fouet en quelque sorte
à la consommation tout en ne n'allant
pas contre un objectif qui doit être
celui et que j'ai entendu exprimer
d'ailleurs par la majorité mais que nous
nous avons exprimé et depuis fort
longtemps nous udi c'est de favoriser la
production nationale favoriser l'emploi
en France donc je crois que l'amendement
est imparfait mais il répond en partie à
cet
objectif chers collègues donc pas
d'autre demande d'explication de vote
j'ai donc été saisi d'une demande de
scrutin par le groupe UMP sur
l'amendement numéro 9 rectifié présenté
par le gouvernement à l'article
1er je vous rappelle donc que la
Commission est est favorable il va être
procédé au scrutin public dans les
conditions fixées par l'article 56 du
règlement le scrutin sera ouvert dans
quelques instants comment
vas-tu
le scrutin est
ouvert
plus personne ne demande à voter le
scrutin est clos j'invite les
secrétaires à procéder au dépouillement
du
scrutin
on aura un
comm
résultat du scrutin numéro 241 sur
l'amendement numéro 9 rectifié à
l'article 1er nombre de votants 347
nombre de suffrage exprimé
335 pour l'adoption 176 contre 159 le
Sénat a
adopté nous arrivons à l'amendement un
rectifié il est présenté par Madame
deoche merci Monsieur le présid
président en dépit de la loi du 1er
juillet 2010 portant réforme du crédit à
la consommation le nombre de ménages
surendettés reste très élevé cet
amendement vise à compléter le fléchage
des sommes débloquées par les salariés
au titre du dispositif exceptionnel
ouvert par la proposition de loi pour
permettre le remboursement de dett
certes la procédure prévue à l'article
r33244-2 du Code du Travail a prévu la
possibilité de liquider les droits
prévus au titre de la participation
avant l'expiration des délais notamment
dans les cas de situation de
surendettement sur demande du juge ou
par le président de la commission de
surendettement mais l'objectif de notre
amendement est d'agir en amont expliquez
excusez-moi encore d'employer le terme
et d'anticiper le risque de
surendettement des ménages qui
présentent des signes de agilité
financière en permettant ainsi le
remboursement des dettes y compris les
crédits
d'irrenouvelabl merci chers collègues
madame le rapporteur quel est l'avis de
la
commission
la Commission a longuement discuté de de
cet amendement cet après-midi
elle a
effectivement partager le le souhait de
Madame la
rapporteur d'aider au maximum à
desserrer la contrainte financière qui
pèse sur les les personnes en en
endettement lourd par contre elle a noté
un certain nombre de d'arguments qui
militent plutôt contre l'adoption de de
cet amendement
d'abord le fait que la mesure de
déblocage vise avant tout à à soutenir
la consommation et non pas à permettre
le remboursement des dette le fait que
dans le cas de surendettement la
possibilité existe déjà mais vous l'avez
rappelé dans votre présentation et
enfin nous nous craignons aussi un un
effet sur le le le problème du crédit
renouvelable autrefois appelé crédit
permanent qui a la différence d'un
crédit amortissable n'est pas par n'est
par définition jamais remboursé
puisqu'il consiste à mettre en à
disposition de l'emprunteur généralement
par le biaet d'une carte de crédit une
sorte d'argent réutilisable au fur et à
mesure de son remboursement pour
financer des achats non prédéfinis donc
c'est notamment cette
cette cet endettement que que vise votre
votre amendement et nous craignons en
tout cas que dans la rédaction qui en
est faite il ne ils ne répondent pas à
l'objectif et la Commission a souhaité
demander l'avis du Gouvernement merci
Madame la rapporteur monsieur le
ministre quel est l'avis du Gouvernement
l'avis du Gouvernement est est dé
faavorable d'abord pour des une raison
assez simple c'est que l'objectif de
cette mesure est une mesure favorable à
la consommation et ensuite nous
considérons que l'objectif qui
consisterait à désendetter une personne
donc à honorer par cette mesure là
d'abord les créanciers et pas la
consommation euh n'aurait pas l'effet
escompté par le dispositif ce qui fait
que nous sommes défavorables à cet
amendement j'ajoute que par principe
nous dans le cas où une personne est
menacée par le
surendettement le fait de préserver son
épargne et qu'il lui soit possible
notamment en commission de
surendettement de distinguer ce qui
relèv des créances prioritaires et des
créances néon prioritaires est important
d'où le fait de pouvoir conserver cette
épargne là et ne pas l'engloutir
totalement au désendettement en
direction d'un nombre de créanciers qui
peuvent le cas échéant attendre et en
commission de surendettement une partie
de la dette peut-être effacée ou reporté
ou
échelonné merci Monsieur le Ministre
alors nous allons voter sur le premier
rectifié explication de vote madame
debr président monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues le groupe UMP votera
cette cet
amendement effectivement je ne vois pas
comment on peut inciter les personnes à
consommer alors qu'ell serait en plus
endetté c'est justement vous avez raison
monsieur le ministre il y a des
possibilités de déblocage anticipé
lorsqu'il y a surendettement il n'y a
pas de possibilité de déblocage anticipé
lorsqu'il y a seulement endettement donc
je trouve irresponsable de dire aux
personnes écoutez débloquez votre
épargne consommer mais surtout ne
remboursez pas vos dettes je trouve
qu'il aura été très intelligent de
pouvoir effectivement permettre à ces
personnes endettées d'être moins endetté
donc nous voterons cet amendement merci
chers collègu la parole est à Monsieur
Marseille pour explication de vote
en particulier pour
lesutomob mais la parole est à Monsieur
la parole est à Monsieur Marseille
j'écoute toujours avec plaisir notre
collègue
Desessard monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre oui effectivement nous nous
soutiendrons le cet amendement qui qui
d'ailleurs avait été présenté dans des
termes similaires par Madame
linman parce que c'est vrai que c'est un
amendement qui nous apparaît de bon sens
on peut pas à à la fois aider à la
consommation ce qui est ce qui est une
bonne chose et en même temps voir un
grand nombre de salariés en en situation
de précarité ou ayant rencontré des
difficultés familiales et donc on sait
très bien que la les les séparations et
cetera entraînent des difficultés très
fortes dans de nombreux foyers les
familles monoparentales sont nombreuses
et donc euh je préside comme ici un
certain nombre d'entre nous un un office
HLM on voit bien les difficultés et donc
c'est c'est vrai que ce déblocage peut
peut-être un appel d'air extrêmement
intéressant pour beaucoup de familles
que ça va que ça va aider et et qui vont
pouvoir repartir sur un pied beaucoup
plus satisfaisant alors qu'elles ont
cette épée de damoclais au-udessus de la
tête et donc je je pense que avec mon
groupe que c'est un un amendement
extrêmement important et et donc nous le
voterons merci chers collègu je n'ai pas
d'autres demande d'explication de vote
que ceux qui souhaitent adopter cet
amendement veuille bien lever la
main
merci que ceux qui sont contre ve bien
lever la
main il n'est pas
adopté
abstention merci deux amendements font
l'objet d'une discussion commune
l'amendement 8 rectifié est présenté par
Monsieur
Cardou monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre après la je sais pas si je dois
qualifier la scène que nous avons vécu
de comédie tragédie euh je j'hésite à
présenter mon amendement parce que je
sais bien qu'elle va être son sort mais
je vais quand même l'expliquer je
voudrais simplement quand même faire
remarquer que une fois de plus le
gouvernement vient de se rendre compte
qu'il n'a pas de majorité au Sénat et
j'avoue que l'épisode que nous avons
connu et bien pour un un jeune sénateur
qui s'imaginait qu'un parlementaire
était élu pour légiférer et faire la loi
ce que nous avons pas voté nous mais ce
qui a été adopté avec ce en particulier
qui n'a aucune valeur juridique et ce
que j'appellerai une incantation et bien
j'avoue que ceux qui nous observent et
qui nous écoutent risquent d'avoir une
fois de plus une piètre un piètre
jugement sur les parlementaires bon ceci
dit j'expliquerai rapidement mon
amendement qui était quand même une
synthèse entre ce qu'avait proposé notre
collègue Isabelle Debray et ce qu'avait
proposé notre collègue monsieur van
lenberg dans la mesure où je laissais
7500 € de plafond pour la consommation
courante et en particulier pour
l'automobile en espérant que ce ne soit
pas des Toyota ou des Hyundai et en
fléchant 20000 € 20000 € sur les travaux
immobiliers parce que flécher 20000 €
sur les travaux immobiliers c'est
respecter l'esprit de la participation
j'y reviendrai dans une explication de
vote et qui est faite pour développer de
l'investissement durable au profit des
salariés et quand on investit dans un
logement ou quand on investit dans des
travaux dans un logement c'est de
l'investissement durable qui permet pour
le futur et bien de de capitaliser pour
sa retraite et je pense que c'est
l'esprit de la participation donc je ne
voulais pas
qu'onacuse la proposition que je faisais
de supprimer une possibilité de
consommation pour les biens courants et
en revanche on fléchait ces travaux
immobiliers dans l'esprit que je viens
de vous dire à concurrence de 20000 € et
surtout ont don un signe fort aux
entreprises de bâtiment qui on le sait
bien sont dans une situation extrêmement
difficile certainement beaucoup plus
difficile que la grande distribution et
je crois que on va pas faire un
commentaire sur un un adage bien connu
en France mais si l'industrie du
bâtiment pouvait repartir on aura fait
un grand pas vers la reprise de la
croissance donc voilà quit le sens de C
amendement je sais très bien qu'il ne
sera pas voté mais j'avoue avoir ce soir
appris beaucoup de choses et pas
forcément dans le bon sens merci chers
collègues l'amendement numéro 2 est
présenté par Madame
Debray merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
j'aurais pu tout à fait retirer cet
amendement si l'amendement numéro 3
avait été voté c'est-à-dire si on avvez
pu siibler les sommes donc jusqu'à 20000
€ effectivement sur des achats
importants comme le ministre souligné
des des achats je dirais pardon pour
Monsieur de cessar mais des achats
durables c'est-à-dire des achats
importants et non pas des
petites petits achats qui pourraient
être effectivement fabriqués hors de
notre territoire donc je maintient cet
amendement en conséquence puisque
l'autre n'a pas été accepté donc cet
amendement a pour but de limiter le
montant des avoirs susceptibles d'être
débloqué je propose un plafond de 10000
€ ce qui correspond d'ailleurs au
plafond retenu pour les PR précédente
mesure de déblocage exceptionnel en
outre ce plafond me semble effectivement
à la à l'issue de nos de nos travaux
plus réalistes cont tenu des avoirs
moyens détenus par les salariés enfin il
me semble important de ne pas mettre en
péril la capacité de financement des
entreprises alors que le nombre d'entre
elles souffre des difficultés à obtenir
des réseaux bancaires les crédits dont
elles ont besoin pour investir il nous
faut préserver les capacités des invest
des investissements des entreprises pour
l'avenir et les emplois qui en décou tel
est l'objet principal de cet amendement
merci chers collègues madame le
rapporteur quel est l'avis de la
commission la commission a émis un avis
défvorable pour chacun de ces deux
amendements merci Monsieur le Ministre
l'avis du
gouvernement même avis avis identique
alors nous votons sur le 8 rectifié pas
de demande d'explication de vote si
Monsieur vin
oui c'est pas vraiment une explication
de vote si ce n'est pour dire que nous
voterons contre ces deux amendements
mais c'est parce que que ce soit dans
cet amendement ou dans le précédent si
on multiplie les les chiffres 7500 10000
20000 bon simplement pour rappeler que
euh les sommes que réellement les les
salariés ont en réserve ne sont bien
souvent pas ces montants là hein il y a
effectivement des moyennes mais pour
beaucoup de salariés pour beaucoup
d'ouvriers cette année l'intéressement
la participation ce sera quelques
centaines d'euros et euh on a tout à
l'heure cité la moyenne de 7500 ça me
paraît un petit peu haut mais en tout
cas pour beaucoup c'est moins de 5000 €
donc là voyez on est dans des sommes
7500 10000 20000 qui sont pas forcément
tout à fait en corrélation avec les
réalités vécues par les salariés c'est
ce que je voulais dire et d'autant que
il y a maintenant un dispositif qui
permet aux entreprises de mettre en
réserve certain nombre de fonds avant de
les redistribuer sous forme
d'intéressement et de participation et
que les fonds redistribués sous forme
d'intéressement ou de participation ont
tendance à diminuer ces dernières années
c'est ce que je voulais préciser merci
chers collègues pas d'autre demande
d'explication de vote que ceux qui
souhaitent adopter le 8 rectifié vez
bien lever la
main merci que ceux qui sont contre veut
main il n'est pas adopté sur le numéro 2
même vote même vote alors nous allons
voter sur l'article 1 pas de demande
d'explication de vote
j'ai été saisi d'une demande de scrutin
public par le groupe UMP sur l'article
1er du projet de loi il va être procéder
au scrutin public dans les conditions
fixées par l'article 56 du règlement le
scrutin sera ouvert dans quelques
instants
le scrutin est ouvert
ah
ou c'est un coup de
divorce je toi tu sais par à ta femme
je elle sait me
parler
demande à voter le scrutin est clos
j'invite mesames et messieurs secrétaire
a procéder au dépouillement du
scrutin
vous voulez pas
le donc
depuis quelque chose je fais mon en
ça ça
éé
du scrutin numéro 242 sur l'article 1er
de la proposition de loi nombre de
votants 347 nombre de suffrag exprimés
326 pour l'adoption 189 contre 137 le
Sénat a
adopté n en arrivons à l'article 1 B je
n'ai pas de demande d'explication de
vote j'ai été pardon madame debr
oui je je vais vous donner une bonne
nouvelle je retire la demande de scrutin
public vous
voyez très bien c'est bien connu dans un
premier temps au bloque et dans un
deuxième temps on débloque et bien je
mets donc au voix l'article 1 bis que
ceux qui souhaitent l'adopter veent bien
lever la main merci que ceux qui sont
contre veent bien lever la main
l'article est adopté je vais mettre au
voix l'ensemble de la proposition de loi
j'ai une demande d'explication de vote
de Monsieur Cardou
oui monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues au terme de ce
texte qui a quand même subi beaucoup de
rebondissement je voudrais simplement
revenir sur les différents propos qui
ont été échangés par rapport à ce qui
s'est passé avant donc tout le monde est
convenu à peu près de d'admettre que la
relance par la consommation n'a jamais
fonctionné vous avez fait référence à
plusieurs reprises à ce qu'avait fait
approuver la précédente les précédentes
majorité ce que vous n'aviez pas voté
vous aviez combattu et vous engouffrez
dans dans un procédé qui a montré ses
limites et ses échecs alors que depuis
un an depuis un an vous avez
rigoureusement démantelé tous les textes
qu'avait fait adopter le précédent
gouvernement qui allaient dans le bon
sens alors la cohérence où est-elle on
démantellele tout ce qui était positif
et quand une fois nous l'avons
reconnu les expériences que nous avons
tenté ont été des échecs et ben vous
vous empressez de vous engouffrer dedans
pour les reproduire donc je voulais
quand même le le le signaler alors sur
les faits je reprendrai
simplement les propos qu'a tenu madame
le rapporteur dans son rapport à la
commission je lis je suis bien
consciente que la mesure de déblocage ne
permettra à elle seule ni de faire
décoller la consommation ni de rétablir
la confiance de nos citoyens dans
l'avenir au terme de Al seul prêt tout
est dit on ne peut pas rétablir la
confiance par voir réglementaire ou
législative c'est ce qu'on essaie de
faire et ça ne marche a pas alors pour
abonder aussi dans le sens de ce qui a
été dit par les précédents
interlocuteurs et particulièrement notre
collègue Isabelle Debray je crois que
nous sommes une fois de plus en train de
dénaturer le véritable esprit de ce
qu'est la participation des salariés au
fruit de l'expansion de l'entreprise
avec ce texte qui date maintenant des
années la fin des années 60 auquel
d'ailleurs et je lui rends hommage le
président ponelet avait pris une part
active dans son élaboration et dans sa
rédaction et la partie anticipation
c'est quoi c'est simplement une voix
intermédiaire qu'avait voulu le général
de Gaulle entre l'appropriation des
moyens de production thèse défendu par
l'extrême gauche et le capitalisme
sauvage thèse défendu par
l'ultralibéralisme c'est ça la
participation et à force de vouloir
faire de la participation ce pourquoi
elle n'est pas faite et ben nous tombons
dans ces outrances et la participation
comme laa fort justement dit Isabelle
Debray n'est pas une variable
d'ajustement de la consommation alors
dans un souci d'ouverture parce que nous
n'avons n'avançons pas masqué nous les
amendements que nous avons proposés
étaient cohérents ils étaient cohérents
dans l'esprit de ce qu'est la
participation et j'ai écouté vos propos
tout à l'heure monsieur le ministre j'ai
retenu deux mots dans ce que vous avez
dit cohérence et ce qui est pas tout à
fait habituel dans le langage de votre
majorité investissement productif et en
fait les amendements que nous avons
proposés allaient tout à fait dans le
sens pour essayer de d'être conciliant
de ce que devait être la véritable
utilisation d'une participation alors
déjà première chose que les sommes
débloquées ne soient pas consacré à
celle investie dans les fonds d'éparne
familiales et le développement des
entreprises et dans les actions comme
l'a proposé notre
rapporteur supprimer les mesures de
contrôle irréaliste voté par l'Assemblée
nationale parce que il y a pas de doute
que conserver toutes les petites
facturette c'est quelque chose pour le
commun des mortels qui est fastidieux
alors que alors que votre majorité Bercy
a supprimé cette année l'accompagnement
des pièces justificatives dans les
déclarations de revenus que dépose les
Français et on y rajoute dans un texte
comme celui-là encore des des
justifications à conserver avec
l'éventuel despé d'amoclesès qui pèse
sur la tête des gens qui l'auraient
utilisé en cas de redressement et puis
aussi aussi et c'était le sens du
dernier amendement que j'avais proposé
et celui qu'avait proposé aussi notre
groupe diriger l'utilisation
l'utilisateur des fonds débloqués vers
une consommation d'investissement
durable plus conforme à la notion
d'épargne salariale institué par la
participation voilà le signal que nous
avions voulu vous donner je pense que
c'était cohérent et bien vous n'avez pas
une fois de plus euh vouloir voulu
saisir la main que nous avions tendu et
bien hein nous voterons personnellement
je voterai contre ce texte comme je
pense la grande majorité sinon la
totalité de mon groupe c'est une fois de
plus une occasion perdue merci chers
collègu la parole est à Monsieur Hervé
Marseille pour expéation de
vote monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je dois dire que ce soir c'est
c'est un peu un cas d'école ici
euh dans ce qui se passe régulièrement
au Sénat ce texte en lui-même appelle
pas d'observation formidable d'ailleurs
chacun l'a dit sur tous les bancs c'est
une démarche que beaucoup de
gouvernements ont déjà emprunté par le
par le passé d'ailleurs à l'Assemblée
national le texte été amélioré dans un
sens jugé favorable par beaucoup et même
l'opposition a dans le meilleur des cas
voté pour ce texte où s'est abstenu donc
c'est pas le texte en
lui-même qui appelle beaucoup
d'observation je dis simplement que le
gouvernement quand il vient devant le
Sénat et c'est régulier et qu'il sait
qu'il a du mal à convaincre sa propre
majorité il doit au moins essayer de
convaincre
l'opposition et c'est mieux quand c'est
avant et donc il y avait des amendements
mon collègue Cardou a parlé de certains
amendements madame deoche a fait un
amendement comme Madame linman
d'ailleurs sur le le problème de de
l'endettement qui aurait pu être mieux
discuté mieux mieux appréhendé mieux
être pris en compte parce que ça allait
semble-t-il vraisemblablement dans le
bon sens pour aux yeux de beaucoup on
est obligé d'avoir des
discussions dont on voit bien la limite
et porter ici en séance de grâce le
gouvernement mène une politique il est
là pour ça c'est sa politique mais il
peut pas avoir raison contre sa majorité
et contre l'opposition à la fois il y a
pas besoin d'être agrégé de mathématique
pour s' rendre s'en rendre compte il
faut faire des choix il faut des
discussions alors Monsieur le Ministre
au-delà du texte ce soir qui nous fait
veiller jusqu'à maintenant pour pour
voter et bien euh à à l'avenir que que
le gouvernement discute plus avec le
Sénat discute plus
euh certes avec sa majorité mais aussi
avec l'opposition et je crois que les
textes s'en ressentiront ils seront
améliorés d'une part et je pense que ils
auront davantage de facultés à obtenir
des majorités ici au Sénat je vous
remercie merci chers collègues je n'ai
pas d'autres demande d'explication de
vote je vais donc mettre au voie
l'ensemble de la proposition de loi
portant déblocage exceptionnel de la
participation et de l'intéresst j'ai été
saisi une demande de scrutin public par
les groupes UMP et socialistes sur
l'ensemble du projet de loi portant
déblocage de la participation et de
l'intéressement il va être procédé au
scrutin public dans les conditions
fixées par l'article 56 du règlement le
scrutin sera ouvert dans quelques
instant
ouvert
demandé commenc
à
personne ne demande à voter le scrutin
est clos j'invite les secrétaires à
procéder au dépouillement du
scrutin
on y
va
CH
Oui
résultat du scrutin numéro 243 sur
l'ensemble de la proposition de loi
apportant déblocage exceptionnel de la
participation et de l'intéressement
nombre de votants 347 nombre de suffrag
exprimés 326 pour l'adoption 189 contre
137 le Sénat a
adopté le Sénat a donc adopté cette
proposition de loi socialiste sur le
débloc exceptionnel de la participation
salariale et de l'investissement une
mesure qui devrait intervenir dès le 1er
juillet prochain et sur ce texte le
gouvernement avait demandé la procédure
accélérée c'est-à-dire une seule lecture
par chambre l'Assemblée nationale
l'ayant déjà adopté le 13 mai dernier il
va donc maintenant passer en commission
mixte paritaire où députés et sénateurs
vont tenter de trouver un compromis nous
quittons maintenant l'hémicycle du Sénat
pour vivre la campagne des mun Mpal vous
le savez Public Sénat vous fait vivre ce
début de campagne et hier soir c'est tan
dalgo la candidate socialiste à la
mairie de Paris qui lançait
officiellement sa campagne pour les
municipales qui auront donc lieu en mars
prochain je vous propose donc d'écouter
en intégralité son discours il avait
lieu